Hello everybody!
Hello, hello, hello!
Oh gosh, okay.
So, welcome, welcome class.
Welcome class to VTubing 101 by Professor Doki.
I just need to let you guys know that I need, before I start, a big disclaimer for all of you.
But this is all my own opinion.
So like, obviously, to each person, it is different how this is done.
I am a very unique circumstance in terms of like, what the fuck happened to me.
So...
So, I just need you guys to know...
This is like, all my own opinion in terms of like, content creation and like, VTubing and stuff like that.
Like, all the tips and advice is...
From what I feel is how to build an audience and how to nurture a fan community.
I realized, I just remembered, I forgot that slide.
I forgot to make that slide.
Regarding like, how to nurture a fan community.
I forgot to make it.
So...
So, I'll talk to you guys about that later.
I was like, I knew I forgot something.
I knew I forgot one thing to talk about regarding like, VTubing 101.
Most important things is like...
How to create a fan community.
Like a community...
A community that is like, you know...
How to nurture it and how to like, grow it in a way.
And making sure they like, you know...
They'll continue to watch you.
So, stuff like that.
I realized, I knew I forgot to make one important slide.
And that was one of them.
So, I will talk about it.
I will sadly...
There won't be a slide about it.
So, I guess like, if you're looking back.
You're just gonna have to remember where I talked about it and stuff like that.
So, like I said.
This is all my own opinion.
In regards to like, all of this.
It will touch on about like, content creation as well.
Not just like, VTubing in general.
Because like, although VTubing is a niche type deal.
It's like, it's own niche within the streaming community.
A lot of these like, things I talk about can also apply to general streaming.
Like, it doesn't have to...
You don't have to be a VTuber.
You could just be like, a Fleshtuber.
Or like, just a PNGTuber.
Or whatever.
It all like, it's just...
Just general advice on like, algorithm and stuff like that.
A lot of this is like, very like...
It's like, very...
What's the word?
It's very...
It might be like, very simple advice.
And it could be like, things like, oh, I knew that already.
Or stuff like that.
But some people might not.
You know, some people might not know this already.
This info.
And stuff like that.
Or like, they might not be aware that like, oh wait, that's the thing.
So, there's gonna be some advice that, to others, might seem very simple.
But might help...
It might help others.
And then there might be some advice that you might not know also.
So, I'll try to touch as much as I can.
There will be like...
I will take questions.
But of course, I will pick and choose what questions I would like to answer.
At the end.
And from chat.
And then I will take some questions.
I will also be reading through the Twitter thread that I made regarding like, people on Twitter.
That have asked me like, questions regarding...
Regarding like, what they want to know more about.
Like, what my process is.
And stuff like that.
So, I will be looking at Twitter as well as chat later on.
To answer some of the questions people have.
Because like, there's some where people were asking me, how do you do a project?
How do you start a project?
What do you do?
Well, like...
This is like...
I didn't make a slide for stuff like this.
Because like...
When doing projects, it's not really that complicated of a process in general.
Unless you get sponsors involved.
Like...
The moment you get sponsors involved.
Or like, you have someone else that's funding it for you.
It doesn't...
It's not that complicated.
It's as complicated as you want to make it to be.
So, I didn't make a slide about that.
Because I felt like...
It really is like, your own work process regarding projects.
And stuff like that.
So like, of course, if you have a sponsor involved.
If you have someone else involved.
Obviously, what they want to do with your project matters a lot.
Because they have a say.
Since they're funding it.
They have a say on how this project is going to go.
So...
Or you can fund it yourself.
Which is basically...
If you fund it yourself, you get 100% on where your creativity is going towards.
It's like how a lot of like, passion projects are usually funded by themselves.
Because they don't want like, a higher, upper...
Person to like, dictate what it's going to be like.
And only...
You just want to do what you want to do.
So it's basically like, if you want funding.
Yeah, you don't have to pay for it yourself.
But a lot of the creative control is out of your hands.
So like, it's like very restricted.
But if you fund it yourself.
Obviously, you have the majority of creative control on how things are going.
So that's why I didn't make a slide.
Because it's like, it really heavily depends on like, how you want to do your project.
So I can give you how to organize your project.
Like, in terms of like, how I organize my projects.
Regarding what the Discord servers will look like.
I can give you guys an insight on like, how I separate a Discord server.
And stuff like that.
So there will be like, pictures and everything.
Don't worry.
This stream will be...
It's archived.
So...
So do not worry.
This stream is archived.
So you guys can rewatch it whenever you want.
Regarding stuff like this.
And I said before, I will not be going over anything that will break any aims.
Or anything that is like, very private information.
I will not be going through any of that.
I will mostly be going through like...
I guess, general knowledge that's already been out there.
Regarding when I talk about like, companies versus indies.
Should you join a company?
Or should you be an indie?
I'll be talking about like, pros and cons.
But all this information is...
A general knowledge.
It is out in public.
So like...
And it's not like NDA...
It doesn't break any NDAs.
All of this information is out in public.
But it's more so I give like, a highlighter.
On like, separating what are the benefits between...
Why people want to join a company.
And why people will want to join...
Want to continue being an indie.
There are pros and cons for each.
When you see the pros of like, company and indie.
You'll see why people will go for either.
And...
There are benefits for both.
For each one.
So...
The first off, I'm going to...
Also, I realized there's no BGM.
But I was trying to find a good BGM.
But I don't know...
I don't know what to use as a BGM.
I mean, I do have this.
A classic.
I could do that.
You know what?
Fuck it.
I'll have this be my BGM.
Alright.
This is going to be my BGM.
Anyway.
So...
We're going to go with the first slide.
We're going to go with a classic.
So...
The first slide.
The biggest factor.
Before I go into any of this.
The biggest factor...
Regarding how to make it.
As a content creator.
And like, as a Vtuber.
Is luck.
And networking.
And like, I'm not going to deny.
That luck pays a huge factor.
If you watch any like video.
Regarding like...
How do I become a content creator?
How do I be a big famous streamer?
How do I become famous?
Everybody will tell you.
That luck is one of the biggest factors.
When it comes to streaming.
To make it as a streamer.
It's your biggest...
Your big break.
Basically.
But...
Even when you have your big break.
You must be able to utilize it.
To keep the momentum.
So like, you can't...
You can't just like...
Have something.
You got your biggest break ever.
But then you don't utilize anything.
Regarding it.
You just coast.
After that.
That kills all your momentum.
Like...
I think that's like...
Really like...
That is like...
Very...
For some people.
That is incredibly obvious.
But there's so many times.
When someone will have their big break.
And then they do nothing with it.
They just coast.
They'll just keep on streaming as if it's normal.
The thing is.
When you get your biggest break ever.
You have to like...
Keep up the momentum.
And...
A lot of eyes are on you at that point.
You gotta grind.
You can't just take a break.
Right after you get your...
Like biggest opportunity.
Because sometimes.
When they get their big break.
They'll be like.
I'm not gonna stream after...
Uh...
I'm not gonna stream after like...
Two to three days.
That...
Your momentum's gone.
You gotta milk it.
I...
I know it's like...
It seems so...
Like...
Simple.
But it's something that a lot of people...
Don't realize.
You can't...
You know you're like...
Oh you have to take a break.
You have to rest.
But when you have a break.
You have the biggest opportunity of your life.
You can't rest until you're stable.
Like...
But the...
The huge thing is that...
Streaming isn't stable.
Content creation isn't stable.
But you have...
But when you have this opportunity.
You have to keep going.
Until you feel like you're safe.
That you won't lose this anymore.
Like...
And like...
That is why I'm like...
I was a huge workaholic when I started out.
And I still am.
Because I do really enjoy streaming.
Um...
It's when...
You feel like...
You're at a safe position.
That's when you can relax.
Um...
Because when you lose this...
The luck...
To your opportunity.
When will you get it again?
Type deal.
You have to go in thinking that you only have one...
Huge opportunity.
And you have to go in...
With...
Milk and...
That huge opportunity.
For as long as you can.
Until you realize...
You're in a safe and stable position.
To relax.
But...
A huge...
Huge...
Uh...
Like...
Negative side to this...
Is that some streamers...
Don't know when...
They are in a safe position.
That is...
Like...
The...
Hardest part.
And that's why a lot of streamers...
And a lot of content creators...
Don't know when to take a break.
Because they don't know when they are stable.
And that's why you see a lot of burnout.
And a lot of like...
Streamers...
Burning out.
Or like...
Just not being able to keep going.
Because they don't know exactly when...
This...
When the right moment is...
To relax.
And that is a huge...
Problem.
Because...
Streaming is also very new.
It's not a very long career.
We don't know the effects of...
Streaming as a long career.
Right now...
We are seeing...
Big YouTubers...
Finally...
Like...
Quitting.
After like what?
20 plus years...
On YouTube.
Um...
We are now seeing like...
Big YouTubers...
Finally deciding to retire.
But those are YouTubers.
We have yet to see the outcome...
Of streamers.
At best...
A lot of the big streamers...
A lot of the famous streamers...
Are still going.
So like...
We are seeing...
Big YouTubers...
Finally retiring.
But we haven't seen...
Big streamers...
Finally...
Taking a break.
Or fin...
Not taking a break...
But finally retiring.
So...
At this point...
We don't know what's...
Happened.
We don't know the career...
Of streaming in general.
Uh...
Jerma kinda retired...
But Jerma is still sort of...
He's still like...
Sort of...
Going...
Ongoing...
Type deal.
He's not really...
Like retired retired.
He's like...
Semi retired.
But even then...
We are not...
He's like...
One of the biggest...
Out there.
Like he is literally...
Okay...
You can say like...
Making it in streaming...
Is 1%.
Jerma...
Is like the 0.001%.
Because...
He has become a meme.
So because of that...
He has like...
Transcended...
To like...
Meme status.
Which means...
It's forever...
Type deal.
So...
It's forever type deal.
And because of that...
Like...
He...
It's a different story...
Regarding like...
Regular streamers.
And so...
There's...
There's lots of things like this...
To worry about.
Like...
You have to know...
When you can relax...
And when you can take a break.
And...
I feel like...
When you have your biggest opportunities...
I personally think like...
You keep going...
Until...
Like...
You can start to see...
That...
Uh...
That your growth...
Has stabilized...
Type deal.
Like...
It has stabilized to a number...
That you think is gonna be your average...
For a while...
And that even if you take a break...
Like maybe like...
One to two weeks break...
I know like some people are like...
A month break or something...
I personally think...
This is my opinion...
But I personally think...
One to two weeks...
Is like the optimal...
Length...
You can take as a...
For a break...
In Vtubing...
And content creation...
And...
Content creation...
Um...
Well content creation is another hand...
But I think in Vtubing...
One to two weeks...
Is the optimal spot...
Um...
If you're in a company...
You might be able to take a longer break...
But like...
If you're an indie...
One to two weeks...
Has...
Is like the optimal spot...
For a break...
Because you're not gone long enough...
That people...
That it will affect your algorithm...
And you're not gone long enough...
That like...
Uh...
That you're not gonna be able to...
That like...
People have...
You know...
Watched other streamers...
And stuff like that...
Um...
One to two weeks is like the safe zone...
Anything more than that...
It's a little bit...
Of like...
A gamble...
It's like how...
It's more so of like...
How much have you like...
Nurtured your fan base...
To be able to...
Uh...
To be able to like...
Take longer breaks...
Um...
This is...
As I said...
This is all my own...
Opinion...
Um...
If you're on Twitch...
You don't have to worry about algorithm that much...
Um...
But like...
If you're on YouTube...
Algorithm...
Is like...
Very, very important...
Um...
Because it affects on...
How much is...
Your content...
Is being pushed outside...
Of...
The regular sphere...
Uh...
So...
It really...
Uh...
Why is it not to work...
Be worried on Twitch?
It's because...
There's no...
The YouTube...
The Twitch algorithm...
Is different...
From the YouTube algorithm...
The Twitch algorithm...
Is mostly just...
You know...
The front page...
With the...
Like...
The streamers you wanna watch...
You might...
Would recommend...
And stuff like that...
But Twitch growth...
Is mostly relied...
On...
Raids...
Uh...
Which I will talk about...
In another slide...
Uh...
Raids and VTuber collabs...
Or collaborations in general...
Really help benefits...
Um...
Twitch growth...
While on YouTube...
Uh...
YouTube growth...
Really benefits on...
The algorithm...
And what you upload...
And...
Uh...
What you're streaming...
And types like that...
Uh...
Raids...
Hard carry...
Twitch...
Uh...
Content creators...
Because you're like...
Funneling viewers...
Into like...
Other...
Other people...
It's very easy to funnel viewers...
To other people...
YouTube...
Is more so...
Regarding uploads...
Like shorts...
Videos...
And like...
Um...
How much you're growing...
And your consistency...
The moment you're...
You're...
Coasting on YouTube...
The less YouTube will push you out...
To other new viewers...
And...
I have a slide...
That mostly talks about...
The algorithm...
And...
Uh...
Matrix...
Thank you for the super chat...
Thank you...
I love gambling...
Ah...
So you're...
You're a super chat reader...
Gambler...
Will Doki read my slide?
Anyway...
Another thing I want to talk about...
Is networking...
Um...
Your growth...
Heavily relies...
On networking...
And...
Who you reach out to...
Who you're working with...
Who you're socializing with...
Um...
How you're growing...
Like...
It relies heavily on...
Your social...
Social skills...
And...
Uh...
How...
How you're...
Open you are...
To reaching out...
To...
To people...
Type deal...
It doesn't have to be...
Like...
Friendships...
And stuff...
It could be just like...
A...
Like...
It doesn't have to be friendship...
You don't have...
You don't have to be friends with everybody...
Um...
It can be just like...
A casual...
Like...
Relationship between...
Business...
Uh...
Partners...
And stuff like that...
Like...
It doesn't have to be...
It can just be like...
A...
Co-worker...
Or something...
And...
Uh...
It doesn't have to be a friendship...
It can be a colleague...
Yeah...
It could be a colleague...
And...
Uh...
And like...
Just someone like...
Mutual...
Like...
Collab partners...
Uh...
So it...
Doesn't...
You don't have to force yourself to be friends with everybody...
Um...
Especially if you're like an introvert like me...
I don't have to force myself to be friends with...
Like...
Everybody I meet...
Um...
Type deal...
Uh...
I don't...
I meet people...
But I don't have to be like...
Force...
Friendships on people...
Because it has to be mutual...
It has to be a mutual friendship...
And like...
There's like mutual...
Um...
Like...
You can...
You feel like you grew with somebody...
Uh...
I don't know...
Also...
Like...
There's...
Stream personalities...
Is not the same as off-stream personalities...
How I portray myself on stream...
I'm like super energetic...
I'm like...
I'm like chaotic and stuff like that...
Um...
But...
I'm also an introvert...
So like...
Uh...
On stream...
It's very easy for me to...
Be like that...
Because like...
I very much enjoy streaming...
And...
Um...
And I very much enjoy streaming and I very like I love like making content and stuff like that.
But like off stream, I am very like chill.
I'm like super I'm like chill and I'm like low energy because I put all my energy into on to stream type deal.
Like I put a lot of my energies on stream and like, you know, my battery is low off stream.
So my off stream is like very different because I most of my energy and most of my battery is on stream.
So like I said, like on stream, maybe you like grew with somebody's on stream personality.
Like the on stream chemistry is is like really, really good.
But me off stream, you're just casual acquaintances.
And stuff like that.
So like I said, you don't have to be friends with everybody.
But it's really good to like know people at least like, you know, know some people.
For example, like Twitch Rivals.
When I got invited to my first time invited Twitch Rivals.
I talked with I talked with like the head one of the head people who organizes Twitch Rivals.
I had talked with them.
I like gave them like ideas and my opinions on stuff.
And I told them like, oh, I really enjoy Twitch Rivals.
It was really, really fun.
If you if possible, can I is it possibly invited in future Twitch Rivals?
Because I really enjoy doing them and I was I could have just like done Twitch Rivals and not cared about it after that.
But instead, I personally reached out to the head of the Twitch Rivals organizer and told them how much I enjoy doing them.
How much like how much my fans enjoying me doing them.
and told them how much I enjoy doing them, how much like how much my fans enjoying me doing them.
And that is how I got my connections with Twitch.
It's because I took the extra step to interact with the pet people who are organizing these events.
And then just be like, I really enjoyed it.
And if possible, can I be invited to future Twitch Rivals?
And that's really it.
That's how I basically got invites consistently to these events.
And just, you have to be like... and I have fun on them!
I do!
It shows in my streams and it shows when I reached out directly to the pet organizers.
And like, that's also like... it doesn't matter.
This applies to everything.
Like events and like... events and all this other stuff.
If you ask directly, the worst they can say is no.
Like, or ghost you.
And you already...
You took your chance.
You took your shot.
Like...
Like, you took your shot and that's all that matters.
And it's all about like, taking your shot.
You have to get onto these opportunities.
And be able to interact with people and like, openly ask about whether or not it's possible to do these things.
Like... and...
I mean, if they ghost you, then you're like, fine.
You move on.
You have to be able to accept reality.
And you have to accept rejection and getting ghosted.
Because that is the way of being a streamer and content creator.
It's gonna fucking hurt.
But like, I got ghosted and rejected for things.
Like... and I'm...
Okay, I'm not fine.
But you have to accept it.
Like...
That's the thing.
You need to accept rejection.
Also, Phreaw, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Sorry, professor.
I almost forgot to pay for class.
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah, sorry.
For those of you who don't know, the tuition.
The class tuition.
Anyway, like I said.
That is one of the biggest factors on like, making it as a content creator.
Um...
But yes, like I said.
Luck is why a lot of people want to join a company.
Because...
Making it into a company is the luck part.
And...
It already comes with an established audience.
After that...
Even when you make it to the company.
It's your job to keep those eyes on you.
And continue building it.
Because it's not like...
You can coast after that.
It's like...
You have to keep going after that.
Or you're just gonna stagnate.
So, um...
Which is why my next slide will be going over...
Um...
Indie versus company.
So, I'm going over company first.
And a lot of this is...
Sort of like, public knowledge.
So, I'm not gonna be going into any details regarding anything that could break NDA.
And stuff like that.
But a lot of this information is like, public knowledge.
That I'm pretty sure...
Like, it doesn't matter if it's like a small company or a big company.
It generally is like...
It's very like, to the point regarding like...
Situations and stuff like this.
So...
Uh...
So like, pros and cons.
So, obviously I'll be going over like...
Why should you join a company?
And also like...
Things to be aware of.
And like I said...
You get an instant audience base.
So, the audience of the company...
And of the Vtubers...
That debuted before you...
Will be there for your debut.
Obviously.
Because...
You might not be the first person there.
You know...
If it's not a new company...
Um... That you're starting...
Uh...
There is already the branding involved.
So you're going in...
With...
You're going in...
With like...
An established audience.
And because of that...
That's why a lot of people want to join.
If you're nobody...
If you came with zero viewers...
Then of course...
Like...
On your debut...
Like... I don't know... 20 plus viewers...
If you come from zero... 20 plus...
100... 200... 1000...
That's a lot from what you were used to.
Um... It draws a lot of attention.
And it's your job to make a good debut.
So you can keep the attention...
Of those people...
Uh...
That watched you.
They don't know anything about you.
But they're all here to be there to watch you.
They know zero things.
Zero things.
Other than what you've given out.
What your skin suit is.
And like...
What your personality is like on Twitter.
And that's it.
That's all the information they have of you.
But even so...
You're going in there with an established audience base.
That are fans of the company.
Or the VTubers that came before you.
And um...
And they're here to watch you.
So you have all this exposure.
Right off the bat.
You could be a hidden gem out there.
As an indie.
Before you sign up for a company.
And it's up to the company.
To reveal...
Why you're a hidden gem.
And uh...
Because there's so many really good indies out there.
That never had their big break.
But it's only because of...
Joining a company.
They received their big break.
And that is why a lot of people take that chance.
Another reason why...
Is because...
You get a group of people...
To collaborate with.
Instantly.
And this is one of the things I've learned as an indie.
How it's...
Very difficult.
As an indie.
Is to find a group of people.
Or a collab group that you want to do collabs with.
And um...
And uh...
Be able to like...
You know organize something really easily.
In general.
So in a company.
You can't really just ask anybody.
Like there might be a server or something.
And you can just be like...
Add everyone.
I want to play this game.
And uh...
I need people to play there.
I need three people.
And that is why one reason...
One of the reasons why people want to join.
They want a sense of community.
And they want a group of people to be able to...
To be able to play games with.
Or like to be able to organize stuff with.
And um...
It's why a lot of people...
Would want to join.
And that makes sense.
As an indie you have to socialize and meet people.
And get close enough to invite them to things.
And when you are in a company.
You don't really have to do that.
It could be colleagues or something.
And you can just be like...
Hey you guys want to do this?
I don't really know you.
But you are in the company.
So obviously let's do something together.
So...
So it gives like a security.
Of like having a group of people.
That you can just work with.
And you don't have to contact people outside of your circle.
To fill in spots or work on socializing.
And the next reason is...
If you are a singer or a dancer.
So the reason why I put that.
Is that it's very beneficial for...
Uh...
If you are a singer or a dancer.
Is that if you have talents in singing or dancing.
To work for a company.
And because of that.
Because the reason is that...
A lot of the biggest events that Vtuber companies do.
It doesn't matter how big or small.
Are concerts.
And like singing.
And if you are talented at singing.
You will get picked to do concerts.
If you can sing.
You will get those opportunities to perform around the world for fans.
Since you are under a group.
You can do big group concerts with lots of other singers.
And it's much easier to set up.
Versus as an individual.
And all the costs are within.
From the company.
And that's why if you are a singer or a dancer.
It really benefits you.
Because like...
Like I said.
You get to be picked to do these types of events.
And...
And these are like one of the...
I won't say the easiest events to organize.
But like the most common events.
To...
To see...
Being hosted by Vtuber companies.
Because it's like...
Some things that fans love.
And some things that is easy...
Not easy.
But like...
They have a lot of experience organizing.
And also like they have access to like...
Music labels maybe.
It depends on which company you are joining.
But...
If you want to be...
Make it more...
If you want to be like...
More well known as a singer.
It's easier to do that when you are joining a company.
Versus being an individual.
Because getting your talents out there.
Is easier because of that.
As well as like...
Not only that.
But cover songs.
Group songs.
Karaoke's.
These are like some of the easiest ways.
To help boost not only your channel.
But the company's branding as well.
So like...
These are like some of the things to be able to do.
That you should be aware of.
Because like I said.
Hosting concerts and stuff like that worldwide.
Is like some of the easiest things to do as an entertainer.
Versus like...
For me.
I think it's one of the reasons why.
I felt like I was...
I'd be slacking off or like not worth much.
Because as a person who can't sing.
Or a beginner.
You have to think.
What can I offer to the company.
That can be used for events and big productions.
And it's harder.
Because you have to be more creative.
And know where your own talents lie.
For me.
I would say like gaming.
But I can't really do that.
I can't have like...
Host like a big event.
Regarding like...
Fan event regarding gaming.
Like it's very like...
Harder.
I feel like personally.
It might be harder to do.
Versus like singing.
So like...
What if we're like...
Oh, but Doki.
What about like tournaments and stuff like that?
It's harder because you can't do like...
LAN stuff.
If you're a Vtuber.
You know.
I mean there's like moments.
Because you can't go to LAN.
So like... that's different.
You can't be like...
Oh my god.
Because like...
I was invited to do like...
Um...
I have moments in the past.
Where I was invited to do things like...
Uh...
Like physical meet and greets.
For like gaming stuff.
Or like I had to be there.
Like I won't show up.
I won't like be there on the stage.
But I had to be there.
Like at the event.
And I had to say no.
Because as a Vtuber.
That is very dangerous.
I said no for these.
Because like...
Uh...
Obviously like risk wise.
Like being there.
Physically being there.
Um...
As a Vtuber there's a lot of risk to it.
So I've had to say no.
To like LAN events in the past.
Where I had to actually be there.
To play the game.
And um...
I didn't feel very comfortable with that.
I didn't feel very comfortable.
Uh...
Because I was worried.
I was worried because I was like...
I don't know if I'll be actually...
If like I'll be safe.
Type deal.
So in the past I have said no to these opportunities.
Um...
Also another thing is...
If the main branch is not English speaking.
But you speak the language.
One of the reasons why I put this here.
Is that you want to apply to...
For a company whose main branch is in English speaking.
I strongly suggest...
Learning that language.
While you're applying.
Or if you make it in.
And because... why?
Because speaking that language...
Offers so many opportunities.
Um...
Including being able to collaborate...
With talents.
And participate in main branch events.
Um...
If it is only in that language.
And signups are exclusive.
To being able to speak that language.
Um...
You're obviously like...
Shutting down a huge...
Set of network.
And a huge set of opportunities.
That you know...
You wouldn't be able to access.
If you don't learn that language.
Um...
It makes sense.
Because you have to be able to communicate with everyone.
And be able to keep the production going.
Another thing is that the main consumer base.
And experience.
Will also be in the main branch.
Most of the sales and consumer products.
Might be exclusive to one country.
Because manufacturing and like shipping.
Is just easier.
You know it's all there.
So...
So like...
It's all there.
Like overseas shipping is very expensive.
So maybe they want to make something.
That is exclusive.
To like this particular country.
Because it's just easier.
Especially if it's like brand deals.
Or like sponsors.
It's like only located in one region.
So it's just easier.
In the long run.
It's hard to learn a new language.
But if you're trying to apply for a company.
Or if you're trying to get into a company.
Whose main language isn't English.
It might as well...
You might as well do it.
If you want to grow as a content creator.
In that company.
Um...
And if you're...
So it's like it's super understandable.
Why it would be very beneficial to you.
Uh...
And like if you speak...
The language.
You might have more fans in the main target demographic.
Thus offering you more opportunities.
To receive sponsors.
Dedicated to the main demographic.
So like stuff like that.
It seems like super simple.
But like...
It's like something you have to be incredibly committed to do.
Um...
You don't even have to be like...
Super fluent.
You could be like...
Semi fluent and that is fine.
It just helps you in the long run.
Um...
Anyway...
You have to have...
Learning language is incredibly difficult.
And it's more so like...
You just have to be like...
Very dedicated to doing so.
And networking also benefits.
Because you can reach out to like...
Different fan bases.
And stuff like that.
Like by knowing...
Because like obviously...
The English fan base might be different from other language speaking fan bases.
So...
The more you know.
The more beneficial it is to you.
Also but if you are like doing...
Trying to cater to both fan bases.
You need to be able to balance this.
So like...
You have to be able to...
The hardest part is being able to balance...
Speaking languages for different audience bases.
Because you have to make sure...
Like one audience doesn't feel left out over the other.
So you have to be able to balance this...
Very well as well.
Because you are gonna like...
You know some people are gonna feel left out.
And you can't stop that.
People are gonna feel left out.
But you have to be able to make sure...
That you are not catering to one side more than the other.
So you have to find like a healthy balance.
My suggestions on these is...
Just maybe have like...
One stream a week.
Dedicated to...
Speaking that language.
Just to keep up with like...
Nurturing that fan base.
Or like...
I feel like...
Just be able to have like one or two streams a week.
Just dedicate it to that.
And...
Another thing is you don't need to worry about like...
Big picture and legal stuff.
What I meant by that is that...
When you are in a company.
All of this is handled by the management.
So as an indie.
What I have noticed is that as an indie.
When you get more like...
Merch collaborations.
Like offers and deals.
There is like contracts and negotiations that you have to be involved in.
Um...
And because of that.
You also have to obviously read those...
Those contracts of like...
The merch negotiations.
Or like sponsor stuff.
Or like...
You have to read the contracts.
Um...
But when you are in a company.
You don't really have to worry that much about the big picture stuff.
Because obviously.
The company will make sure it wouldn't like hurt them.
Regarding like sponsors and merch stuff.
So like you put your trust in that.
But when you are as an indie.
You have to make sure that like...
Even if your manager is reading as an indie.
Even if your manager is reading that.
You have to read it yourself as well.
Because what...
You are doing.
Doesn't necessarily mean that that is what you want.
So you have to be able to read your contracts.
And negotiate for things you want.
And that is obviously like a lot of work.
Anyway another one obviously.
Is like 3D.
Obviously companies are very well experienced.
With having...
Doing 3Ds.
And having 3D done.
Like they have all the experience.
And I would say people in Japan.
Companies in Japan.
Have the most experience with doing.
Vtuber 3D stuff.
Because you know.
They have like perfected it.
They perfected it.
And I feel like in NA.
A lot of companies in NA are still playing catch up.
When it comes to what JP companies have done.
Or not just JP companies.
But JP indies too.
Um...
Indies in Japan.
Also have like really good 3Ds.
Because a lot of studios in Japan.
Are very well versed.
In doing anime 3Ds.
NA are still doing catch up.
So there is still a lot of time.
Like there is still a lot of catch up.
It's also a lot of work.
3D in general is a lot of work.
So...
But that is like one thing that can offer.
As an indie you might not be able to have that opportunity.
Because as an indie.
Um...
Getting a studio that is able to.
Be able to handle all of that.
Having the assets made as well.
The thing about like.
Like Japanese companies.
And Japanese like 3D tech.
Is that a lot of them.
Have already have assets made.
From the past.
That you can use.
Um...
So they are always keeping assets.
That can help benefit them more in the future.
Um...
It is a lot of money invested.
And they have already invested so much money.
That is why.
That is why like it is much more difficult.
As an indie.
And if you are really looking forward to an indie.
To doing 3D and stuff.
There is a reason why you want to join a company.
And finally sponsors.
It's easier.
You don't have to reach out for sponsors.
Like a lot of times.
You don't have to make a fucking deck.
Like...
You guys don't know.
You have to have a pitch deck made.
As an indie.
But like for sponsors.
The company will already provide.
Like your company will be working on finding these sponsors for you.
And uh...
So for those who don't know what pitch deck is.
Is basically a pitch deck.
Is basically a...
Like a thing that you send to companies.
To like business companies.
Or sponsors or brand deals.
To like advertise yourself.
And it's like as an indie.
And it's like as a portfolio.
Because like that is your way of like advertising yourself.
As like a portfolio.
To advertise yourself to like other companies.
But when you are part of a company.
You don't have to worry about that.
Your company will be doing all that.
And they will be picking people who they want to do.
To represent particular brands and stuff like that.
Like you don't have to worry about anything.
You get a sponsor.
You will just be pleasantly surprised.
Like...
Now things to be aware of.
Number one.
You are like I don't know.
Things that you need to be aware of.
Because if these things are not Gucci with you.
Then you are going to have a rough time.
Like...
So...
If you are not cool with any of these things.
Then you are going to have a rough time.
You are going to have a really rough time.
So one of them is...
Permissions.
Obviously...
When you are in a company.
It doesn't even matter.
Even if you are in any company.
Even if you are like in any company.
This is like one of the things you have to worry about the most.
Because like...
Because you are not cool with anything.
You are not really safe.
Because they see you as a corporate.
So you are not really safe in general.
Umm...
And...
And there are more...
Yeah companies are more...
More like looked at.
Regarding perms.
It doesn't matter what country you are in.
It really...
If you want to be really smart about it.
If you are from NA.
You can play NA games.
But when you start playing games.
Or like you try to do stuff outside of NA.
That's when things get messy.
You might have fair use laws.
But you are part of...
But even then that's not really going to protect you.
Umm...
When you are playing things or doing things.
And the country of origin is not America.
Or Canada.
Or just not NA.
So...
Like I said.
You need permission for things.
Music, games and others.
What do you mean by others?
Graphics, pictures, images, videos.
Everything.
If you think showing pictures of something.
If you guys didn't know.
Umm...
So there is like a lot of like many things.
That a lot of companies are like really strict about.
Like one of the...
Like I can give so many famous examples.
But I won't.
Because I don't want to get in trouble.
Hahahaha.
I don't...
But if you look hard enough.
Like you can find them.
And obviously like some of the things.
That obviously you should be like.
Umm...
You guys didn't know.
Like you can't make like fan products of Sanrio stuff.
Because they are very strict.
Regarding like...
Umm...
Of like Sanrio things.
So like stuff like this.
Umm...
You can easily get stuff taken down.
If you put like I don't know.
Some like Hello Kitty stuff that wasn't made by Sanrio.
Like you made your own Hello Kitty product.
They will try to take it down.
Because like it's not made by them.
And stuff like that.
You have to be worried.
It's not just music and games.
There are so many other things to worry about.
And you might not be happy that you can't get the permission that you want.
For certain things.
And you are very restricted on the games you can play.
And like obviously music as well.
So like...
Umm...
Maybe like...
Maybe some game companies don't give you explicit permission.
And stuff like that.
So there are some things like this to worry about.
Maybe this is like your favorite game of all time.
You really want to play it.
Like you really want to stream it.
But you can't.
And you have to be able to accept that.
Someone says...
Is this only for Japanese companies?
No.
A lot of like smaller companies...
In NA have to deal with that too.
Because they don't want to worry about...
Like...
Umm...
Because like maybe if it's an NA game...
That's fine.
If it's an NA developer and publisher...
Umm...
Then like you know...
That's fine.
But if you're trying to do something that's outside of NA...
Umm...
Then it's...
It's more of a risk.
And obviously when I say other...
Like someone said what about mods?
Stuff like that.
You have to get the permission from the original creator.
Usually some of them would say no.
Hahaha...
So...
But you have to have an explicit...
Explicit permissions for stuff like that.
So... Umm...
It doesn't matter.
Like mods, stuff like that.
Like fan translations.
Like you have to worry about things like that.
Obviously like I said certain restrictions to follow.
Like not only just with games and everything.
It's how you handle yourself.
And maybe like...
You're not allowed to do certain things.
Or say certain things.
Because like you represent the company.
And you have to be aware of what you say and how you act.
Because what you do doesn't just reflect yourself.
But the whole company.
So you have to be aware that your stance...
Reflects the company's values.
Your image and beliefs are tied to the company.
So like you have to be very aware.
And if you join a company.
You have to be very neutral in a lot of things.
You cannot...
It's...
Because like you don't want it to hurt yourself in the long run.
So you have to be incredibly neutral.
You have to be sure of like when you say things.
Of like I like this thing.
That it's safe to say.
Hahaha...
Like...
That's what you have...
Because you're representing...
No you're not representing yourself.
It doesn't matter if that's your own opinion.
You represent the company.
So it doesn't matter.
You have to be neutral.
You're here to entertain.
You're like...
You have to be like incredible...
You have to be safe.
And everything.
And even then.
If you are an indie that's planning to join a company.
You have to make sure.
You're like...
I guess like brand friendly type deal.
You have to be like brand friendly.
Because like...
What you say on the internet is forever.
It doesn't matter.
If it's like oh that was before.
Before then you know.
What you say on the internet is forever.
So you have to be sure that like you know.
You're pretty much like your...
Your like internet history is like...
Okay.
Hahaha...
Yes the internet never forgets.
Um...
And then obviously another thing is...
Juggling your schedule.
Regarding overlaps.
You don't want to over...
If you're in a company.
You want to be like respectful to other people's schedules.
So like maybe like oh...
This person is going to have a sponsor stream at that time.
I don't want to overlap it.
I'm going to make sure to...
Rate into the sponsor stream.
Because like...
How well they do in sponsors might mean...
Like the sponsor would want to do more with us.
So stuff like that.
You have to be very smart in how you arrange your schedule.
And everything.
So you have to be sure that like...
Um...
That you're like helping everybody.
Not just yourself.
You can't just focus on yourself.
You have to be sure that you're helping everybody.
If everybody grows...
That's a good thing.
You're a team player.
So it's very frustrating.
Especially when you're like...
Oh I really want to do it at this time slot.
But you have to be a team player.
Because you have to make sure that everybody is like...
Going well.
So that in the long run you will go well.
You will do well in the long run for everybody.
Um...
And it's all about like working together type deal.
So...
And obviously like I said like percentage cuts taken.
I think that's like very self explanatory.
When you're working for a company.
It doesn't necessarily mean you...
Obviously like they take a percentage.
So because they're like funding some things.
They're helping you in some stuff.
They are arranging things for you.
Stuff like that.
So it's obvious.
So that is why people would want to join a company.
And those are the pros.
And like...
What you have to be aware of.
Of what you have to do.
Um...
So now you're wondering.
Okay what about an indie?
So as an indie.
Basically it's like opposite of obviously...
A lot of stuff I said regarding company.
So as an indie.
Um... Like I said.
There's more freedom what you can do.
You're an indie.
There's so much more freedom.
I mean...
There's...
A lot more!
Yay!
You have all the creative control.
On everything you do.
And how you want your channel to be.
And you get to keep 100% what you make.
Because you're by yourself.
You're an indie.
Like I think...
Sorry I accidentally smacked something.
So...
Uh...
Thank you.
Take this 100%.
Also I just realized I never asked you guys how the sound was.
I hope the sound has been okay.
So far.
I hope the BGM has been like okay.
It's not too loud.
Um... It's a bit low.
Okay that's great.
That's fine.
You just want to listen to my voice anyway.
Why do you guys want to listen to that BGM?
It's all about the information I give you.
Uh...
Okay.
I boosted a little higher.
Alright.
I'll give it a little higher.
Alright so...
Anyway as I was saying.
Um...
And your networking connection stays with you.
So like you don't have to like...
You know...
Everything... your connections and all of that directly goes to you.
It's not directly from the company.
You know?
You don't have your connections from the company.
You have the connections from yourself.
So everything just funnels to you.
Um...
And then you get to create the merchandise you want to make.
And guide the production.
So like I said.
The thing about being an indie is just everything is up to you.
How you want to make your career.
Everything.
But of course with more freedom comes more risk.
So...
Because of that.
You're opening yourself up legally to more like risk.
That you might not be prepared of.
So like...
Obviously...
You see like scams.
Stuff like that.
And you have to like make sure.
You have to have a...
Depending on how big you are.
As a content creator or a Vtuber.
Or if you want to try and get to learn these things.
Um...
You will eventually have to have a business lawyer.
That can help you look over contracts.
Especially regarding like...
You don't want to be taking advantage when it comes to like sponsors.
And um...
And brand deals.
You don't want to accidentally take a bad sponsor.
There's like liability and stuff like that.
So you have to have a business lawyer.
That's there to read your contracts.
And um...
And be able to like...
Help you with stuff like this.
So...
You also have to work harder when it comes to networking and branding.
Because it all comes down to you.
Obviously you don't have the company brand.
To like help you with...
Uh...
Help you with getting to know people.
Or uh...
With networking and branding.
You have to build this yourself.
You have to build this up all about yourself.
And then you have to be smarter with this branding.
In doing what is meta.
Like you can't...
Unless you want to be niche.
But niche is also harder.
Variety is an easier route.
Versus niche streaming.
Because niche streaming.
When you're doing niche streaming.
You're restricted to that certain niche.
You can't really branch out.
Because the moment you branch out.
Your viewership.
Will not follow you.
It doesn't matter if you're like.
No they love me.
Your viewership most likely will just find another streamer.
That might be streaming that particular niche.
So you don't want to cater.
It's better for long term streaming.
To be a variety streamer.
Because when that niche dies.
You are in trouble.
You have to really like figure out what to do.
Um...
Or you cater a very far niche.
To a very fucking dedicated fan base.
But that in itself.
Is also very difficult.
So like someone said.
If you only stream that one thing.
Those viewers will only show up.
For that one thing.
So you have to.
Long term wise.
Variety is better for you long term.
Even though it's harder to get started.
Variety is better to have.
Versus like being a niche streamer.
Um...
And...
When you are in a company.
You can go niche easier.
Um...
But because you are under the company brand.
So like there are viewers that would be like.
Oh I love just watching people in this company.
So like it doesn't.
It's like it doesn't matter for you.
If you are a niche in a company.
But when you are a niche as an indie.
It affects a lot more.
Um...
Uh...
Thank you.
As an indie.
Is this still a good idea?
Do you get perms for games, covers, etc.
Or is it unnecessary as an indie?
If you are doing reaction content.
I would highly suggest.
Don't risk it.
On your channel.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Or put it on Twitch.
If you want to do reaction content.
Just do it on Twitch.
And then like.
And that way.
And then like edit it in a way that has.
That benefits fair use.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Like.
I would say that.
If it benefits.
And if you are going to react to something.
And you think you can upload it on your channel.
Make sure the thing you are reacting to.
Is something within NA.
And not like outside of NA.
Because then if it's outside of NA.
It's harder.
Because you know.
Some countries might not have fair use laws.
Or you pay the creator.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Regarding games.
Music.
Covers.
I would say.
Cover songs.
Um.
Look up.
Song permissions.
If you are doing Japanese covers.
Look up song perms.
For like Japanese songs.
Because like.
They have the right.
To take down your song.
If you don't have proper permissions.
Um.
And if you are doing like.
Maybe if.
And then also like English songs.
They might get copyright claimed.
But like.
Or like.
But it doesn't affect your channel.
Stuff like that.
They will just take the revenue.
If you are okay with your music.
Having your revenue taken.
Um.
Then that's fine.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha ha.
That's.
It's okay.
Because the most common factor.
For like English songs.
Is mostly like.
They just give you like a copyright claim.
Where they just take your revenue.
And unless you are just there to like have views.
That's okay.
But if you actually want money from doing cover songs.
Um.
Then you have to make sure.
That like that particular song you are covering.
Um.
Is okay.
Perms wise.
That you won't get claimed.
Ha ha ha ha.
Um.
What else?
Uh.
But yeah.
As I said.
You have to follow it's meta.
So fear of missing out games.
So you saw me like a difficult.
What was it?
Supermarket simulator.
Uh.
What's it?
The climbing game.
Um.
Stuff like that.
You have to be on it.
The moment you realize.
It is the streaming.
Streaming game.
You have to be on that shit.
Ha ha ha ha.
It's.
That's it.
Because people want to watch those games.
And that's really.
You have to flavor up that week.
So you have to make sure you play it.
Because you don't want to miss out.
Ha ha ha ha.
It's all about the meta.
And how do I figure out.
What's flavor of the month streams?
You literally look at the biggest streamers.
Out there.
That do variety.
And they are on that shit.
The moment it releases.
How.
What's an easier way.
If you don't know which streamer to watch.
Go on Twitch.
And look at most popular game being streamed right now.
And that's how you find.
That's how I found out.
Supermarket simulator.
And the climbing game.
I literally go like.
I was like on Twitch.
And I saw.
I was like.
What's this?
Everybody's streaming it.
All the flesh tubers are streaming it.
And I was like.
Wow.
This is clearly the streamer game.
So like I decided to play it.
Because I was like.
If people really enjoy it.
If a lot of people are watching it.
Clearly it's a very entertaining game.
And there's some games.
That doesn't matter.
There's some games.
Like elder wilds.
I highly recommend streaming games such as.
Elder wilds.
Because those games are like.
Games that have discord servers.
Dedicated to it.
Ha ha ha ha.
And.
It's basically like.
Um.
I talked about this before.
But there's like games.
That have like cult fandoms.
So like.
Elder wilds is one of those games.
Where there's a discord server.
Dedicated to like finding streamers.
That are streaming elder wilds.
Because they want to chase the high.
That elder wilds gave them.
Ha ha ha ha.
Because they want to live vicariously.
Through the streamer.
Streaming elder wilds.
So like.
Souls games and elder wilds.
Are some of these games.
Or undertale too.
Souls games, undertale and elder wilds.
Are one of these games.
That are really well known streamer games.
Because there are servers dedicated to finding other streamers.
That are streaming that game.
Because they want to live vicariously.
Through that game.
Ha ha ha ha.
So if you're starting out.
These are like some of the fucking.
They're the reason why.
They're called stream games.
They're the reason why they're called the streamer meta.
Or the stream games.
And every fucking streamer.
Doesn't matter what streamer you are.
It doesn't matter if you're a vtuber.
Or a fleshtuber.
Or whatever content creator you are.
They love that shit.
Ha ha ha ha.
And also gotcha game.
But like if you're starting out.
I don't know.
I feel like you should invest your money.
Unless you want to be a gotcha streamer.
But like.
And you think you're gonna have your investment pay off later.
Or you're really fucking passionate about gotcha.
But if you're starting out.
A lot of your money is gonna be spent on reinvesting in your channel.
Um.
So like that's why I was like avoiding gotcha.
Because like.
Um.
Because you're investing on the gotcha instead of the channel.
So.
But if you're really passionate about gotcha.
Then feel free to do gotcha.
Like I'm not gonna restrict you.
Ha ha ha ha.
Anyway.
So by the way.
I have like 17 slides.
And I realized we're...
Some of them are like really fast.
I think these two were like my longest slides.
But I hope it's been like informative.
So far.
I hope this has been like informative.
For you guys.
And like good advice.
Alright.
Okay.
Auditioning.
Obviously I won't be giving out audition secrets.
Um.
But like I've talked about this before.
If you guys look hard enough you guys can find an archive.
But like.
When I got to.
When I passed the first round.
I researched a lot.
And I had a 10 page document.
Um.
Going into round 2.
I um.
I went.
I was like submitting a video audition.
Of like stuff like that.
And then when I realized my video audition passed.
I made a 10 page document.
Detailing like.
Everything about.
Preparing myself.
To the next round.
And I was very.
I like worked very hard on that.
And all in there was like research and stuff like that.
Um.
Obviously I can't give out my document.
But I can give you advice on how to look research.
Similar ways.
Um.
There's lots of resources out there.
From members within companies.
That reveal very crucial.
Audition advice.
And insight.
Onto the interviews.
And the audition tapes.
Like.
If you look hard enough.
You can actually find members.
Not just like.
You know like members from different branches.
That talk about.
Specific info.
Regarding the audition stage.
I personally looked at.
Twitter and YouTube.
In different languages.
To find audition interview questions.
So like.
I highly recommend.
You guys.
If you want to audition.
And a lot of times.
I would believe the audition questions.
Would be like super similar.
Like because it's like.
How many different types of questions.
Can you ask about Vtubing.
So.
It doesn't matter.
So like.
It's like stuff like that.
And then.
When you're doing your application.
You have to find.
Your niche.
And main character type.
That you want to play.
Because they're trying to find a character for you.
They're trying to.
They're trying to figure out like.
What will you bring.
Will you have.
Will you be the same personality.
That they have.
Like they already have.
Or will you be a new personality.
Or will you be a personality that has.
That is similar to like one of their popular talents.
And they want to try and.
Like you know.
Have another talent that is just as popular.
Stuff like that.
So you gotta figure out what you're bringing.
And like how to market yourself type deal.
And um.
You just have to figure out like.
What you're bringing to the table.
And we have to know.
That like there's more competition now.
Because VTubing is.
Still is growing.
And like there's a lot of people that want to be.
Want this to be their big break.
A lot of like hidden gems.
That want this to be like.
Uhhhh.
Just want this to be like.
The thing that you know.
That's gonna like.
Make them famous.
So there's more competition now.
And like.
What I submitted.
Back then as a video audition.
Might not have fucking worked.
Later on if I try it.
Like try it now.
Like it will not.
I personally think it will not work.
So like obviously the quality wise.
Might be a lot higher.
Depending on what type of company.
You want to apply for.
It's definitely must have changed.
I would assume it has changed.
Because the market is bigger now.
And the competition is a lot higher.
And if you really really really want to be.
In a.
No matter what company.
You want to be a company Vtuber.
Don't be afraid.
Of applying over and over.
And over and over again.
Until you make it in.
Like if you like.
Getting ghosted.
Not ghosted.
But like usually if you are rejected.
On the first round.
You wouldn't even get an email.
So like there is like guidelines being like.
If we don't reply back.
Within x amount of months.
Try again.
Just try again.
Just keep submitting.
A lot of people would be like I just kept submitting.
Until it worked.
And like at that point.
If you really want to join, just keep submitting.
But also, don't slack off on streaming as an indie.
Just keep going as an indie.
Keep going as an indie and keep submitting.
That's really it.
So you just have to keep taking your shots.
And that is really auditioning.
Equipment!
Alright!
Number one!
Audio!
Audio is so fucking important!
I will not watch a stream if I hear shitty audio quality.
That is like 100% for me.
This is my opinion.
But like, I will turn off a stream if the audio is this fucking shit.
That shit is so important.
Audio...
That fucking shit is so important.
So remember...
To have good audio.
Like, if the first thing you're gonna do...
Is invest...
Please invest in a microphone.
A good quality mic.
And...
It is...
Very, very...
Okay.
I started out with a cheap $1 mic.
Because...
I didn't care.
This mic I bought when I used to live in Asia.
So like...
I was like...
I just wanted a mic to communicate with my teammates.
It wasn't about streaming.
Which I later used for streaming.
Um...
I was like streaming like Overwatch.
So like...
It didn't really matter that much.
Um...
For me.
So like later on...
When I got a little bit more serious...
I upgraded to a Blue Yeti.
Because Blue Yeti at that time...
Was like a...
A...
Budget...
I guess you can say budget.
But it's still pretty expensive.
When you're starting out.
Like I know it says budget.
But like...
Um...
It's still like...
A pricey microphone.
Um...
And...
Uh...
It's...
It's actually like a good starting out mic.
Uh...
If you want to...
Earn the snowball.
Honestly like Yeti products.
But I went with Blue Yeti.
Uh...
But obviously a cheaper alternative will be the snowball.
Um...
But yes.
When I started getting more serious later on.
If you want to be a VTuber.
It's a huge investment.
Similar with flesh tubing.
You have to have like...
You know...
Like the cap.
Like the camera and stuff like that.
It's a huge investment.
And obviously like...
Uh...
You have to be willing to...
Put money onto this.
Doesn't matter.
Skin suit.
Rigging.
All that stuff.
You have to be willing to invest.
In all of these things.
Not all of these.
But like...
If you want to like have a career.
You have to be able to invest in this.
Um...
Anyway.
As I said.
Audio.
If you're investing in anything.
If you don't want to invest too much.
At least invest in better audio.
Um...
Like I said.
Get a mixer.
I have an old GoXLR.
But that is baby mixer.
Because I'm stupid.
If you talk to audio people.
They will be like.
Oh don't get the GoXLR.
You know about mixing.
But I am stupid.
And GoXLR.
Is like baby's first mixer.
And it's for like stupid people.
Like me.
Because it's like very...
What's the word?
It's very...
It's like very intuitive.
It's very direct.
If you know how to use audio.
I would suggest asking.
Your audio friends.
Like people who are in music.
To recommend you.
Better mixers.
And what are mixers?
Mixers make sure you don't fucking peak when you're talking.
So when you're laughing.
When you're screaming.
Stuff like that.
Mixing...
Mixers is a way to make sure your audio doesn't peak.
It's nice.
Um...
When you're whispering.
It's not fucking terrible.
You can mute stuff.
But you have to.
Like you can mute audio.
So that people can't hear.
But you can hear.
Stuff like that.
So like that's what you can control.
Your collab partners.
And stuff.
You can control your collab partners audio.
But that's why I go with the GoXLR.
It's very intuitive.
And very like...
Also there's sound effects.
Stuff like that.
But that doesn't really matter to me.
All I...
I use the GoXLR to help me with like...
Making sure for collabs.
And making sure I don't peak.
When I...
When I like talk too loud.
Or if I scream.
Stuff like that.
It just...
It helps a lot.
It normalizes your audio.
Audio balancing is so fucking important.
Audio...
You can use OBS audio filters.
But it's not as good as a mixer.
It's not...
It's not as good.
But like I said.
GoXLR is baby's first mixer.
And like all the audio people would fucking judge you for using a GoXLR.
But you're stupid like me.
That is all you need.
Like...
I do not have the brain capacity.
To fucking research stuff like this.
Or be able to use an actual real mixer correctly.
Like...
If you look at what real mixers look like.
They look so fucking complicated.
That I can't be bothered.
So...
Obviously other mixers are cheaper.
Like the actual real ones.
Uh...
Hahaha...
But...
But GoXLR is so good for babies like me.
There's just too many buttons.
I can't.
I can't handle it.
There's so many buttons and sliders.
What the fuck does...
I don't know.
I'm not an audio person.
I just stream.
Anyway...
You have to ask around.
If you don't want to go with GoXLR.
Um...
Anyway...
So like I was saying.
Uh...
The reason why audio balancing is so important.
Is that...
When you are in a collab.
A lot of times.
Not a lot of times.
But there are some viewers.
That will only watch the streamer.
That has the best audio balance.
So...
You might not be...
You know...
They're like...
Oh hey I want to hear everybody.
You know?
I want to hear everybody.
I want to know what everybody is saying.
I want to know what everybody is talking about.
So they want to have...
Want to go to a stream.
That has the best audio balancing.
And they'll look at all the other streams in the collab.
And be like...
Oh this stream has the best audio balancing.
I'm going to watch this stream.
So I can...
Um...
So I can figure out...
Like...
I can hear everything.
And stuff.
So that is why audio balancing is very important.
And I have an audio guy.
I have an audio person.
That...
Um...
I have a person.
That...
That watches my streams.
To make sure my...
My audio balancing is good.
I personally have a person that looks at that.
And they are also like...
They are an audio person as well.
They like work on music and stuff.
So I personally have a music person.
To make sure everybody is balanced.
My sound guy.
Um...
And that's why I'll be like...
Sound guy!
I will sometimes look at Discord.
Because I will have them on Discord.
And they'll be like...
Is the audio good?
And stuff like that.
So...
Um...
That's what my sound guy does.
Because I want to make sure that everything is okay.
And that is very important.
Like I said.
There's viewers that will only watch a collab stream.
With a person that has the best audio balancing.
Um...
And it's all about maximizing the comfort of the viewer.
So you know.
You can ask your friend to be like...
Hey can you check my stream?
If you don't...
You don't have like a person really to like...
Really check on your audio.
You can ask your friend.
Like...
Don't ask chat.
Because chat is not a hive mind.
Hahaha!
You can be like...
Hey chat.
How's the audio?
Never fully trust chat.
Because chat is not a hive mind.
And it really depends on the headphones.
On whether or not like the audio is good.
Some people say yes.
Some people say no.
And then you don't know who to listen to.
Find one person you trust.
Very much.
To not...
To monitor your audio.
And then just monitor your audio.
For the first like one minute.
To make sure everything is good.
And then...
At that point.
Then you can...
They don't have to be there.
Hahaha!
They can be...
If they want to.
They can be there.
But like...
If you're asking a friend.
You don't want to force them.
I can literally see my baby go XLR.
Tell me that I'm not muted.
This is why you get a mixer too.
So...
So people can troll you.
Hahaha!
Also TV.
Thank you for the five gift of chips.
Thank you.
Hahaha!
So...
So having a sound person dedicated to monitoring your balance is like really helpful.
Especially long term.
Um...
Because like I said it really affects it.
Anyway...
So I gave you guys my timeline of like what the microphones I use.
So I use a cheap one dollar mic.
Then I evolved to a blue yeti.
And then I used an AT2020.
And then I moved on to the Shure SM7B.
The Shure SM7B is my current microphone.
That I use at the moment.
I'm planning on maybe in the future to upgrade my microphone again.
But only more so of like whenever I get my PC upgraded.
Um...
I will upgrade my microphone as well.
So for now I'm keeping my Shure mic at the moment.
But this is like my timeline of everything.
Um...
If you are a singer.
If you want to get started into singing.
These are not singing microphones.
Hahaha!
I need you guys to know this.
These are not singing microphones.
These are podcast microphones.
So if you want to sing.
I would suggest asking your fellow friends who are singers.
Or research singing microphones.
Because there is like...
Singing microphones are way different.
Hahaha!
I would highly suggest not singing with these microphones.
You need a different mic.
I personally don't remember what mics you need.
Because when I sing.
When I record things.
I just go to a studio.
Or I just like...
Or I sing with my Shure microphone.
Because I don't care.
Hahaha!
It's the studio or my Shure microphone.
Because I'm not a singer.
So like...
I don't care as much.
Hahaha!
But if you're serious.
Get an actual singing mic.
And...
And like research on that.
I can't give you the research for that.
Because I don't know.
Hahaha!
That's really...
Really I can say about like microphones.
Everything else in my opinion.
Is just a bonus.
Everything else.
Like as long as you have good...
Like when you're starting out.
I don't care.
I think all the other stuff.
You can just invest in the future.
When you have the money.
But if you want to start your career.
I would...
The main thing you focus on investment wise.
Is the audio.
Everything else bonus.
It doesn't matter.
Until you get like...
You actually make money.
Hahaha!
Anyway.
Um...
For example.
Like this is my other equipment.
I have three monitors.
It's for efficiency wise.
So I can reach out on one side.
I have chat on one of the monitors.
My right monitor.
That's vertical.
And then I have OBS and other browsers and stuff.
On my left.
I have my main content.
If it's a game.
In the center monitor.
So like the game will be in the center.
And then right now.
My...
My notes is in the center.
So I can read it.
And everything.
So um...
So that is like why I have three microphones.
If you want to get an iPhone.
I would highly suggest an iPhone X.
Or higher.
Because that is the best for facial tracking.
Due to the inbuilt facial tracking.
When it comes to VTubing.
So I would highly suggest.
If you want really good.
Like really good skin suits.
An iPhone X or higher.
Um...
Obviously.
Take a PC or dual PC setup.
A dual PC setup means you don't have to have incredible parts.
Like you don't have to have like...
Oh sorry.
I mean three monitors.
I don't know what I said.
But I meant three monitors.
I meant three...
I don't know.
Did I say three PCs?
I meant three monitors.
You can either have an incredibly tanky PC.
Or you have a dual PC setup.
Dual PC setup doesn't require you to have like really insane parts.
Because it helps like...
One PC will be used for streaming.
And then the other PC will be used for games.
Or like other stuff.
So like...
That's really it.
The reason why having a good PC helps is that...
VTubing apps...
Take up a lot.
Sometimes.
And...
Plus whatever game you're streaming.
Sometimes you're like...
Oh why are you lagging?
Why are you losing frames?
I stream this game.
I don't have any issues with it.
But we also have like...
Us on the screen.
So that takes up a lot of space too.
So...
That is why when you're VTubing...
It requires more resources.
So I highly suggest...
If you're going to invest...
Invest on a better PC.
Or invest in a dual PC setup.
And...
Also a lot of the current games are...
Fucking terribly optimized.
Optimization is shit.
So...
So you have to worry about that too.
So like...
That's why like...
You just had to have a better...
You just had to have a better PC now.
And...
My headphones is the DT770 Pro.
I don't know that matters.
I don't know anything about headphones.
I asked one sound guy about it.
And then they like recommended this headphone.
So then I bought it.
But like I honestly have like...
I don't know.
If you can try and copy my headphones too.
I also have fiber internet.
Because...
My niche in a way...
I'm more variety streamer.
But like I do have like a subcategory.
Which is competitive FPS.
By the way I'm gonna be in Twitch Rivals for Apex Legends next week.
So...
Great segue.
But ping really matters to me.
So that's why I have fiber internet.
But obviously like...
Really not every place has fiber internet.
But yes anyway.
Alright.
So that is the equipment.
I hope that is helpful.
Regarding equipment wise.
Alright.
Twitch versus YouTube.
Okay I know like it's like very brief.
But I also have like more stuff to say about it.
As well.
So Twitch versus YouTube.
Should you stream on Twitch?
Should you do YouTube?
Or should you multi stream?
Um...
The thing...
Okay so I am primarily on YouTube.
It's because I'm used to it.
Um...
I also...
I like having set up.
Schedules.
Um...
I don't like streaming whatever I want.
Because uh...
I'm super fucking indecisive.
I like knowing what I'm doing.
I used to not.
But then now I'm like...
I like knowing what I'm going to do.
Um...
So like...
Because it helps me plan my day and time.
Uh...
Anyway.
Like I said.
For Twitch.
The biggest benefits of Twitch is the rating system.
Uh...
Which benefits you.
Because if you're starting out.
Rates help so much with growing your presence and channel.
So YouTube has raids.
But like it's not as utilized as Twitch.
Because it's harder to find people to raid.
Because like the YouTube rating system is...
Uh...
Is like not as useful.
Usable, I guess, in a way.
It's like...
It benefits companies more than it benefits individuals for YouTube.
But on Twitch, it benefits, you know, everybody.
Like, individuals.
Like, if you're an indie, Twitch rating benefits more so than YouTube rating.
Because, like, there's not a lot of YouTubers on YouTube as an indie.
And it's harder for discoverability on YouTube versus Twitch.
The thing about Twitch is that there is, like, an option to look for, like, lower viewed streamers on Twitch to find raids.
Like, there are moments when, like, you know, bigger content creators on Twitch will go to a category.
The thing about YouTube, you can't go to a category and, you know, find people you want to raid.
And also, like, not everybody...
Not everybody has the option on.
If you guys don't know, if you're starting out on YouTube, the rating is off automatically.
You have to turn it on yourself for YouTube rating.
On Twitch, it's on automatically.
So, like, on Twitch, you can, like, go to a category and be like, I want to raid somebody in this category.
And then you can, you know, browse through and be like, oh, I want to raid somebody in the VTuber category.
And then you'll be like, oh, this person doesn't have...
Doesn't have, like, a lot of, like...
Uh... people...
Uh... you know...
Oh, did I spell it wrong?
Sorry, I can't be bothered to fix it.
But you can go to the category and be like, oh, hey, this person doesn't have a lot of viewers.
I'm going to raid them.
There's a lot of success stories like that.
For example, Nicewig blew up because Dizzy...
And for those who don't know Apex, I'm just going to do Apex terms.
Um...
The reason why Nicewig blew up was because Dizzy was browsing through Apex Twitch streamers and found Nicewig on Twitch streaming in the Apex category.
Dizzy at the time was the Apex streamer.
Um...
Was like the biggest Apex streamer at that time.
And he raided Nicewig.
And Nicewig took that big luck opportunity and rode it to where he is now.
And...
Um...
And it's stuff like that.
Like now, Nicewig is like one of like the biggest known Apex streamer out there.
He is like the official B caster for ALGS.
Stuff like that.
So like that is why when you're starting out and you want to hit...
The easiest way to hit your biggest break is on Twitch.
Maybe later on you can move to YouTube.
But I think if you're starting out...
This is NA by the way.
NA.
If you're starting out...
I don't know for other countries.
But you're starting out...
I would say Twitch is your biggest bet in terms of making it.
On YouTube it is a lot harder for an Indie.
Because there's less discoverability as a YouTuber.
Um...
As an Indie YouTuber.
It's a lot harder.
And um...
More so streaming is a Twitch thing for NA people.
For English speaking audience.
If you're a streamer you're on Twitch.
YouTube is still trying to figure this out for NA.
I was just lucky to be able to do YouTube.
Because I already have an audience established on YouTube.
Um...
So it's a lot easier.
It's a lot easier to get started.
Um...
It's better to start on Twitch and then move on to YouTube.
Because I think long term...
Uh...
YouTube is better.
Monetary wise.
Because you have everything in one channel.
You have the VODs.
You have videos.
You have shorts.
Everything is one channel.
Twitch.
Usually you just have the live stream.
And then you upload it.
Edit it versions of your live stream to your YouTube channel if you want to.
Um...
Twitch is just streaming.
Usually people don't watch VODs on Twitch.
People will watch edited content on YouTube of your Twitch VODs.
So...
Uh...
So that is why...
Like...
Long term...
I feel like YouTube is just better long term.
If you want to do long term wise.
If you're a Twitch streamer...
And you want to have a presence on YouTube...
Have your VODs edited into highlights.
Don't just upload VODs.
Because like...
Sometimes people can't fucking watch 2 hours.
Hahaha.
Uh...
VODs.
Hahaha.
We all have short attention spans these days.
Have a VOD channel too.
If you really want to.
And you want to keep the VODs.
Have the VOD.
Just keep it.
I don't know.
But...
If you really want to have a presence...
On YouTube.
Upload edited versions of the...
Edited highlights...
Yes, people would rather watch edit highlights than a fucking 2-3 hour video.
If you want to upload your VODs, have a separate VOD channel.
The reason why I don't upload my VODs, my Twitch VODs, onto my YouTube channel, my main one, is that that affects my algorithm so much.
Because I know, personally, because I'm like that too, that not a lot of people would want to watch like 3 hour plus of something that's already happened.
They'd rather watch it live.
And because of that, I have a separate VOD channel.
Because I know if the VOD performs not as good as my other stuff, it affects my algorithm and YouTube is like, what the fuck?
YouTube would be like, whoa, what happened there?
Don't...
Moki, why is your channel fucking tanking from this one video?
And I had to separate it because I know VOD channels are the meta and you have to have it separate.
Like, if I'm going to upload a video, it would be highlights.
And that's the way.
You have to appease the algorithm.
It's all about playing the algorithm.
All right, but what about multi-stream?
Yes, you can multi-stream.
It's a very popular method right now, especially in NA.
I don't think like other countries people are doing multi-streams.
It's mostly because like it's mostly an NA thing.
I personally don't do multi-streams because I don't like splitting the audience.
I don't like...
Because you can only have one chat up there and like I don't like... I personally don't like this.
This is my own personal preference and that is why I don't multi-stream because I don't like splitting the audiences.
And like I don't like cultivating different cultures of viewerships because...
Because like Twitch culture is different from YouTube culture.
And then if you choose... if you multi-stream, you only have one chat up.
And then obviously if you have one particular chat up over the other, more people will go on to that stream.
Because people would be like, oh you're gonna be paying attention to that chat.
So I rather pay attention to one singular chat from one platform.
And just juggle I make one my main and the other different.
So like that is why I uhh I like I don't do multi-stream.
But I know that others do multi-stream because it's really good for growth on both platforms.
You don't know which platform is your main platform and you want to grow as a creator.
You do small...
If you're a small streamer, you can do both because it's very good for growth.
I don't do both because I want to focus on nurturing one community.
And focus on one community versus trying to split myself too much.
Because I do better focusing on one thing rather than two things.
Because I'm stupid as hell.
That is why.
Obviously, as a newer streamer, multistreaming is good for you.
I would personally say multistreaming would be a good benefit for you.
But growth-wise, Twitch is the way to go for growth-wise if you're a smaller streamer.
Anyway.
Also, as a Twitch streamer, there is different...
There are different cultures.
Like I said, there are different viewer culture and streaming cultures.
On YouTube, there are a lot of things you have to do on YouTube.
And that was one of the things that was the most stressful for me.
It was because adjusting to this.
I need a schedule.
Before going more serious in VTubing, I would just stream whenever the fuck I want.
I didn't have a schedule.
I didn't make thumbnails.
And I didn't plan anything.
I just streamed.
But...
Um...
When you're getting serious on YouTube, YouTube viewers, YouTube VTuber viewers, they like schedules.
They like thumbnails.
And they like it when you plan stuff.
But also, you have to realize that because you have a schedule, viewers will pick and choose what they want to watch.
So, like, um...
You know, sometimes you stream something.
You know they're gonna...
They know you're gonna stream this.
But it's not gonna be a stream.
It's not something they want to watch.
So they don't show up.
You have to...
You have more of an inconsistent, like, concurrent viewers.
Because...
Um...
Because, like, you know, they don't want to watch it.
Well, on Twitch, viewers are like, they don't care.
No, they do care.
They do care.
But, like, a lot of times when you're watching...
You're on Twitch when you're watching.
They don't really have...
They do play whatever the fuck they...
They just go like, today I want to play this.
And then I got to swap to that.
And now I'm gonna do this.
And now I'll do that.
There's no, like, actual, like, you don't know what's gonna happen type deal.
Um...
But you're always there.
You're just there.
You're there for them type deal.
You don't care what they're doing.
You just want to be there.
Like...
So, like...
So, like, Twitch viewers...
They're more so of like, whoa, what's gonna happen?
It's more...
We're just here.
It's very unpredictable.
But then, like, YouTube, they're like, oh, I don't...
They're like, oh, they're gonna play this.
I don't really want to watch that.
So, I guess I'll just miss it.
Like, it's more so like, I'm not really into that game.
I'm just...
I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna watch something else.
You know?
Like...
Like, it's stuff like that.
You're just...
But, Twitch viewers, you're like, I'm just happy to be here.
So...
Oh, shit.
Chat disconnected.
Am I still alive?
My chat disconnected.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I'm back on.
Did I...
Was I still alive?
I don't know.
My chat disconnected.
Oh, I was.
Okay.
For some reason, my chat disconnected.
So, I was like, whoa, am I still alive?
Okay.
Anyway.
So, I'm back on.
Um, that's basically it.
So, you have to be aware.
Like, even so...
You're still cultivating a fanbase on Youtube.
But, like...
Twitch viewers...
Like, YouTube viewers have an excuse.
Twitch viewers don't have the excuse to not watch you.
Because they're like, what if I miss an important thing that's gonna happen?
Because I wasn't there.
I don't know what's happening.
And another thing...
So...
So it's like, you don't know, they don't know.
They don't know, they have to be there.
Because they're like, what if...
Oh my god, what if she's just gonna play my favorite game?
And I'm gonna miss out!
Yeah, the fear of missing out.
Yeah.
What if I miss a game that...
Oh my god, she's gonna play a game that I really like.
I don't know that.
But what if she does?
Like, you don't know.
So you're there.
You're there no matter what game you're playing.
And then...
The fear of missing out.
But YouTube, you're like, she's gonna play that.
I fucking hate that game.
I'm not gonna show up.
I personally like structure more.
I don't like randomly picking games and stuff.
Because like, I just want to focus on one thing.
I just want to focus on one thing and then be good with that.
Like, I don't like...
I don't... I like more of a structure.
Because I'm very indecisive.
And I rather just know what I'm doing.
I'm super indecisive in general.
And then there's like memberships and stuff like that.
Like in Twitch, the thing is, a lot of Twitch streamers, they have Discord servers.
But like, Discord servers for like, which is like the substitute of the membership stuff on YouTube.
YouTube offers memberships.
On Twitch, you don't have to...
There's like subs.
But you're not required...
You're not like incentivized.
To have like, you know...
Sub only streams.
Stuff like that.
Um...
And YouTube, you are.
Because like, it is a benefit to be a YouTube member.
There's more exclusivity.
Being a member.
There's more stuff to it.
There's a different culture.
On Twitch, subs don't have like exclusivity on there.
There's no exclusive stuff.
Other than like Discord servers.
I know like a lot of like Twitch VTubers.
A lot of Twitch content creators.
They have like a...
Uh...
Discord server dedicated to be like the membership stuff on YouTube.
Um...
So, it's more so of like...
And then there's the emote stuff.
You can use the emote everywhere.
And stuff like that.
Um...
And...
It's more so of like...
Obviously, when you're a YouTube streamer...
Cater your...
Not cater.
Cultivate your membership stuff.
Make it appealing.
Don't just have like nothing really.
I do member streams every other week.
To have something.
And I have like membership plans.
Like exclusive membership stuff.
Like exclusive gaming sessions.
And exclusive like Minecraft member server.
Like stuff like that.
There's like...
Exclusive wallpapers that are being made.
Um...
So that people wanna want to keep...
Uh...
Wanna keep being a member.
So, don't just like...
Make sure to have something there.
To make it worth...
Being a member.
As a Twitch sub...
You don't really have...
Like...
Twitch you don't really have...
Other than emotes.
There's no...
Like...
The Twitch sub appeal is the emotes.
It's not like the...
Like...
Cause you know...
YouTube emotes you can't use it.
You can only use it in one channel.
But Twitch emotes you can use it in every channel.
You can use it everywhere.
That's the appeal.
Uh...
If you're on a...
Highly recommend...
If you're gonna be a Twitch streamer...
To have good emotes.
Because sometimes...
People subscribe to you for the emotes.
I've had that happen before.
There's been multiple cases of people...
Um...
Just subscribing on Twitch.
Because they just wanna use cool emotes.
Like...
If you wanna appeal...
To have good subs...
To have like more subs on Twitch...
Have nice quality emotes.
And make sure they're like memorable.
Or stuff like that.
Like make sure like people would wanna have it.
Like they don't care about your content.
They just wanna have good memotes.
Like...
Some people actually do it.
It was a huge thing.
A couple of years ago.
There would be streamers that were known as like...
Oh my god.
They're like the bear emotes.
I only want them for the bear emotes.
Like that's it.
They were known for like their emotes.
That was it.
And like people actually did that.
People actually just subscribed...
To have good emotes.
And like...
If you really wanna like...
If you really wanna like appeal...
To like more people...
Then do that.
It's fine.
It's just another way to like...
Have a more...
Stable like...
I guess like stable income.
Alright anyway I think...
Is that everything I have?
Everything I have for YouTube.
I think that's everything I have for YouTube versus Twitch.
Alright.
The algorithm.
I love the algorithm.
Yay.
Alright.
Algorithm.
So shorts if you're on YouTube milk the shit out of shorts.
Shorts are being heavily pushed by YouTube for a while now.
I thought they would stop but they're still doing it because they want to take over TikTok.
The reason why is that you know we might not even have TikTok anymore.
So YouTube is like we're gonna be the next TikTok.
So they're heavily pushing shorts at the moment.
Because of that.
Even streams by the way.
You might be seeing a lot of people streaming shorts like...
Like live streams in the shorts category.
Because like when you're browsing through like shorts.
YouTube shorts.
You can get like...
Like live streams now too.
From like random people.
So like yeah a lot of vertical streams.
Because like it just shows up on your fucking algorithm.
It just shows up.
You just scroll through and then some streams show up too.
And it's like...
It's really good for building the audience.
Because that's what the algorithm pushing right now.
The meta is shorts.
Everybody just wants to watch on their phone.
Everyone just wants to watch on their phone now.
Because I don't know dude.
We just have very short attention spans these days.
We're not really helping ourselves.
Hey but don't put all your eggs in that basket.
Because you can upload your shorts to TikTok and Instagram.
Apparently Instagram reels are also blowing up now too.
But like that's...
If you want to cater to the normies more.
Like...
I would say...
You can work on like Instagram reels.
If you really want to like cater more to like the normies.
Because like all the normies are in Instagram right now.
So I mean I think they're still using Instagram.
I don't know.
I haven't used Instagram so fucking long.
But like...
It's Instagram reels.
TikTok and YouTube shorts.
There's a lot of channels right now.
That are at like 1 million to 2 million...
Like 1 million plus subscribers.
And all they do is just shorts.
They don't upload any videos or like do any live streams.
It's literally just shorts.
Because that's what YouTube is pushing right now.
There's like...
I've seen...
I was like watching...
Looking at some of the channels.
That are like...
They upload videos.
But the videos would have like 20k views or something.
But then the shorts would be like 30 million and 40 million.
And they'll have like 1 million plus subscribers.
It's because they only push shorts.
I would highly suggest and highly recommend...
That you do shorts.
You don't put everything on shorts.
You still stream.
Just remember to stream.
Because you need to keep your audience.
You stream and shorts.
You stream, upload shorts.
What I used to do...
Is that I would upload a short...
Every time I'm not streaming.
Because like the YouTube algorithm...
Is so fucked up.
That if you don't upload a thing for a day...
They would be like...
Whoa, that's a bad mark on your algorithm.
I'd be like...
They'll be like...
You're not uploading now?
So...
Back then...
I would upload a short whenever I'm not streaming.
Because I would be like...
Oh no, I can't keep up the algorithm.
Now, I upload a short even if I'm streaming.
Because I want to keep a consistency.
Because I'm just starting out.
And right now, I have like a huge boost in my algorithm.
So I have to keep going.
And because of that, I keep going until like...
The algorithm boost has stagnated.
So that is why I personally...
Am uploading shorts even when I'm streaming.
I have three editors.
Each editor edits at least two shorts per week.
So I can keep this consistent schedule.
That is because I am willing to...
I have the money to invest in it.
Obviously, not everybody has the money.
I have to like edit it themselves.
And stuff like that.
I have three editors to...
So they can...
I don't want to overwork one editor.
So I have three editors.
And I give them a chance to edit two shorts per week.
If they don't want to do it, that is up to them.
If they want to edit more, that is up to them.
But I...
I have...
Because I don't want to overwork one editor.
So I separate it into three.
And I have a whole server set up for them.
So that they won't like overload each...
They won't like overlap each other.
And that is why I can able to keep the consistency.
Of like having a short almost every day.
To keep this algorithm boost.
Because I have a fucking insane algorithm boost right now.
Like I'm fucking everywhere apparently.
Like...
And that's what I mean when I said it's all about luck.
You can't just coast.
You have to know when you have the boost.
When you have the algorithm boost.
You have to be consistent.
Regarding keeping this algorithm.
And that is why I've been trying to keep this algorithm up.
And...
And that is why I have three editors.
To keep this up.
But like I said you might see a lot of people streaming short section.
Because like I said the stream will be fed into the short scrollers.
That's why everybody is streaming in a vertical format.
In a vertical format now.
Also we are doing shorts.
I remember I saw on Twitter.
How do I pick the moments.
I let my editors pick the clips.
Because if they see a good...
How do I find my editors?
I hire clippers.
That is why clipping is so good.
If you want to get noticed as an editor.
As an editor.
Or like if you want to get jobs as an editor.
Be a clipper.
Clip some of your favorite Vtubers.
Clip some of your favorite content creators.
Because they know what's good content.
And that is why.
I hired clippers.
Because.
I hired some of these clippers.
Some of their videos.
I researched their videos.
And they have like millions.
They've got like millions of views on their videos.
Or like they got like 500k views.
On the videos that they clipped themselves.
And then I was like.
And they would clip me.
And I would be like you are a good clipper.
I'm going to hire you.
And that is how I found my clippers.
My editors.
I basically.
If you really want to try and get your name out there.
Just start clipping your favorite content creators.
Because that's how they research.
I don't normally pick like random editors.
I clip somebody that watches me.
Because they know what's good content.
That I bring.
But if you can't afford to.
I highly suggest.
When you try.
You're like.
Oh but what if I'm making my own clips.
Then.
Um.
Uh.
Then.
Look at your chat.
And see which part.
Has the biggest fan response.
Like chat response.
Because usually.
Because there's like an analytic thing.
Where you can see that.
So like when you see an analytic.
Which one has the most like chat engagement.
That is usually where the best content is to clip.
Because people would be like.
Oh.
Like.
Like a lot of chatters started.
Talking so much.
In that one moment.
That must have been a good part.
And then you watch it back.
And you're like.
Oh that is a good part.
I'm gonna edit this myself.
Um.
Obviously.
Learning to edit.
Is like a skill.
I don't know how to edit.
And that's why I pay people to do it.
I'm more of a producer.
I am a producer.
More so of.
Of like.
Um.
Being able to do.
Like editing.
And stuff like that.
I have.
I'm an idea person.
Um.
I.
I admit.
I am an idea person.
And I like to produce things.
Um.
And.
Editing is really hard.
I can't really give much advice.
Regarding editing.
Because.
Uh.
Addy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Here's my tuition.
I can't really do much.
Regarding giving advice.
On editing.
So I really suggest.
Like looking up.
Like tutorials.
Or like asking around.
Uh.
But.
Anyway.
So like.
That is basically how.
I go about with clipping.
With like editing.
And stuff.
Um.
There's another way.
To do like.
There's different types of edits.
You can do.
Right now.
Since I am an indie.
I am much more free.
To experiment.
With my editing.
Um.
It's more so.
Of like.
So you see like.
Back then.
It was just mostly clips.
And like animated clips.
Now.
I'm more so.
Experimenting.
With how.
My shorts are done.
There's more so.
There's like story time stuff.
Story time is very popular.
I would say.
For Vtubers.
If you really want to blow up.
With shorts.
Story time.
Is the best way to go.
And anything to do with relatability.
Is the way to go.
If you have a story.
That shit.
Will do so well.
Um.
It's all about.
Tangents.
Story time.
And relatability.
Between.
With the clips.
And that is like.
The clips.
That would blow up.
The most.
With grinding shorts.
Um.
To blow up.
Into like.
The normie sphere.
Like it goes beyond.
Just Vtubing.
Um.
So people can be like.
She's just like me.
For real.
If you look at my shorts.
My most popular shorts.
Is the.
Um.
Is the one where.
I bought the sticker.
And the waking up stuff.
Like I'll be like.
Oh I.
I wake up.
I eat breakfast.
I sleep.
And people be like.
Oh my gosh.
She's so relatable.
She's the pre.
I'm sorry.
I saw that.
So one of my comment was like.
Oh my god.
She sleeps so much.
She's so depressed.
It's so relatable.
I saw that.
I was like.
What the fuck.
Anyway.
That was like.
One of the comments.
I saw.
Um.
But like.
As I was saying.
There's a lot of.
It's all about like.
Or like something.
That's like.
So wrong.
But like.
People would want to comment.
To like.
Bait engagement.
Or something.
Cause like.
I'll be like.
You know.
Like one was like.
My dream sponsor.
Is a Funko Pop.
Um.
And then.
And then I was like.
Yeah.
And then obviously.
People in the comments.
Would be like.
What the fuck.
Why Funko.
Why not a nendoroid.
And stuff like that.
Because like.
You know.
That gives comments.
And likes.
Also.
It's still my dream sponsor.
Because it's so fucking funny.
Okay.
Like.
It's like the biggest endorsements you can get.
In the normies sphere.
And you're supposed to break the normies sphere.
It's so great idea.
It's a great idea.
Cause people who don't know what the fuck you are.
Will buy Funko Pop.
Because Funko Pop collectors.
Will always be like.
Only collect.
Don't give a fuck.
Don't collect anything.
They like.
Just want to collect Funko.
Have such a community.
Their community is all about.
Collecting everything.
It's like.
It's so.
I don't know.
That's why.
I could be like.
The Vtuber in that fucking collection.
It's just smart.
It's so fucking smart.
Like.
Anyway.
Because like.
Nendoroid collectors.
They collect parts.
If you don't have a good part.
They don't care.
Cause Nendoroid collectors.
They are not here.
They are here to make new.
They just want the parts.
And the faces.
And stuff like that.
Or like.
They are fans of the show.
Like.
There is.
But like.
Nendoroid collectors.
Like the hardcore collectors.
They are not collecting the figures.
They are collecting the Nendoroid parts.
Like.
So they can mix and match.
But Funko Pop collectors.
They collect everything.
They might be like.
I don't know what that character is.
But I want it.
But I also love a Nendoroid too.
Because that's also a dream.
Cause they look amazing.
I used to be.
I used to be a Nendoroid collector.
Not a Nendoroid parts collector.
But like a Nendoroid collector.
Like.
Like the not hardcore collector.
Of Nendoroids.
I would buy Nendoroids.
Because I would be the best.
I would be like.
Oh I like.
I would buy Nendoroids.
Cause I would be like.
Oh I like this.
I like this.
Character.
I don't know what character this.
I was like a Funko Pop version of a Nendoroid collector.
Because I bought like that.
I bought a Nendoroid.
Where like.
The character was riding on a bird.
Thing.
I don't know what the fuck.
Who the fuck this character is.
I was like.
Look at that beautiful bird mount.
I want it.
I still don't know what character it is.
I still don't know.
I just thought it was so cool.
Cause I was like.
I've never seen it before on a Nendoroid.
It was back then when like.
Nendoroids didn't have like.
Those like.
Second mount character things.
And I was like.
That's so cool.
No it wasn't Final Fantasy.
I have no idea.
Anyway.
Fuck you.
We're off topic.
We're off topic right now.
I'm just kidding.
Okay.
Anyway.
FOMO games.
The fear of missing out.
Streamer games.
I already explained about that already.
I already explained about like FOMO games.
But it's.
You know.
Like I said.
There's like.
You don't want to miss out.
Lots of viewers don't want to miss out.
So.
You have to play them.
Great examples.
Chilla Arts games.
So many VTubers.
But I don't know.
I don't want to miss out.
I want to play Chilla Arts games.
Because.
Chilla Arts is like.
The epiphany.
Of FOMO.
They don't want to miss out.
Rage Gaming.
Too.
I don't want to miss out.
Because it's all reaction baiting.
It's there to bait reactions.
And they love.
Making.
They love seeing the reactions.
Of like.
The VTubers streaming this particular section.
Or this VTuber.
That's why horror games is so popular.
Like.
But you can't always do horror games because if you're always streaming horror games, then like, uh, then like people get tired.
Unless that's your niche.
But even if that is your niche, you still have to be able to balance it out.
Because people will just get like too much horror, you know?
It's just be like, it's just like, oh, she's just gonna scream at that part.
And then you're like, it's the same thing.
Like, oh, she's just gonna get jump scare.
It's just, you're just gonna get desensitized.
It's why horror streamers are... horror streamers were a niche.
It was meta because people love watching streamers scream.
But then the meta died.
It's all about the stream meta.
You say PewDiePie and Markiplier and Jacksepticeye, they all used to stream horror stuff.
But now they don't.
They don't stream that much.
Like, if you watch their streams, they like don't stream horror that much anymore.
Because the meta died out.
They don't... it's not the meta anymore.
PewDiePie is a great example of a content creator that knew when to swap metas.
Like...
He swapped so many times with metas because he knew what was... what was gonna be the next meta.
He was like a reaction... he fucking swapped a reaction content.
Because he knew that's what people wanted to watch.
And he was like... I would say like PewDiePie was one of the first like starters.
And he was like...
I would say like PewDiePie was one of the first like starters.
Of like reaction content.
Like the one of the biggest people that like knew what like...
Like that like pioneered reaction content.
Because he knew that's what people wanted.
People like reaction content.
That's what fucking rides the algorithm.
And then it got... it turned into something... I don't know.
And then he does like vlogging now because he's a dad now.
He's super chill.
He doesn't need to do anything.
He's super fucking chill.
Like he's a dad now.
He has so much money.
Like he doesn't have to... he just does it for fun.
He just
does stuff for fun.
He doesn't have to care about the meta anymore.
Like he has the money to not care.
So like that's like his plus side.
And also comments and likes!
Commenting and liking is so beneficial.
It actually helps boost the algorithm.
So if you like this... that's why people like comments.
And subscribe.
Or comment and like this video.
I don't really say it because like... I don't know.
I don't want... it feels too normie.
I know it just feels too normie.
But it actually helps a lot.
It really does help the engagement.
Like I could end up saying... I'll be like...
Hey!
At the end of the vlog I could be like...
Make sure to comment, like and subscribe.
But like I don't do it because I'm lazy.
Okay to be fair.
One of the main reasons why I don't do it is because I'm fucking lazy.
But also...
It's a little cheesy and it's like super normie.
So...
So that's why...
That's why I don't really do it.
I don't tell people to comment, like and subscribe.
But it helps!
If you wanna help like an indie Vtuber.
Or like an indie.
Or like a small streamer.
Comment and like and subscribe.
Like comment and like their videos.
Like all their fucking vlogs and all everything.
Because it helps the algorithm a little bit more.
Because YouTube fucking likes that shit.
And I don't know why.
Anyway...
And also...
Like I said...
Follow the trends!
You guys know what the newest fucking weird ass trend is?
I'm not doing it because it's like...
It's pretty fucked up.
I don't care that much.
I would follow like some trends if it seems fun.
But if it's like too much...
I just think it's just too much.
I don't.
Um...
But like the newest trend right now...
Is the green screen trend.
And that is like where...
Because it like baits engagement.
It baits like...
Whoa!
Shock factor.
So like basically what they do is that they...
There's a green screen.
And like on their body.
And then you have like the gameplay with on their body.
So like that's the...
That's the engagement bait.
Like...
And yeah.
That's like the current trend.
It might change later.
But that is the current trend.
You can say that...
I think the NPC thing was a trend as well.
Uh...
Did you know 80% of my viewers are not...
Subs...
Did you guys...
Actually...
I think mine is like 20%.
I think 20% or like 10 to 20% of my viewers are not subscribed.
So like...
I think that one was mine.
Um...
But yeah.
Anyway.
Thank you Super Chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Spirit.
Um...
But the NPC stream is also a trend.
It's a trend.
So you follow trends.
Obviously it baits engagement.
And it baits like...
Uh...
Like a shock value.
Or like...
Oh!
That's something new!
Oh my god!
They're doing something new!
Like they're doing something funny.
Something new.
Oh my god!
Haha!
Like stuff like that.
Just follow trends.
And then songs!
Songs are really, really good!
Like if your cover song hits like a million views...
Whoa!
Good for you!
Congratulations!
It means you have done really well.
It's really good.
Because people...
Some people will subscribe to you.
Because they really like your songs.
Because they really like your singing.
Like you...
They will then put it on your playlist.
Also Spotify!
You can make so much money on Spotify.
If you just upload your song on Spotify.
I would heavily suggest if you have a fanbase.
If you're starting a fanbase as a singer.
Or an utaite or utaite.
You start uploading things on Spotify.
You can actually make a lot of money.
From Spotify.
If you have like...
Um...
Enough songs.
Or like...
If you have like...
Um...
Enough like...
Uh...
Exposures.
I'm not sure because people put it on repeat and like songs on Spotify on repeat does make a decent amount of money.
And it's only... it's only like... I know some people were like, oh, there's like big streamers.
But you have to remember a lot of the bigger streamers have other companies taking the cut of those streams.
Like the like big singers, like the like the... what was it?
The Billboard singers, you know, like, like I'm trying to think.
Like if we talk about Taylor Swift's old management company.
Taylor Swift, if you guys don't know why Taylor Swift is re-releasing her album.
It is because if she... the reason why Taylor Swift is re-releasing her album is because her old album is owned by her old music label.
And her old music label is... is like... basically owns that song.
Okay.
And because of that, she barely earns money from those old... her old music.
So like that's why you see like, oh, but all the big music stars, they don't earn that much.
But when you're a smaller music singer, you actually earn a pretty decent amount on Spotify.
But you have to remember, it's better if you make original songs versus like cover songs to upload on Spotify.
Because obviously a lot of artists might not let you upload cover songs on Spotify.
But you gotta have permission from the...
the artist to be able to upload those songs.
So like it's better to... if you have original songs, it actually... you can actually like make back your money type deal on Spotify.
Because like it actually is very beneficial to you as a... grow... to grow as a singer.
Um...
And... uh...
So like if you're a singer...
Fucking do covers!
Do so... do as many covers as you can!
Original songs!
If you're a really talented singer...
Just do it!
Because it's so good for your growth!
It is really... it's just a lot of money invested!
But if you want to market yourself as a singer...
This is the way you have to go!
Um...
This is the way you have to go.
You have to... you want to market yourself as that.
Uh... if singer then sing!
Exactly!
Uh... so like...
A lot of people that subscribe...
For like singers, they just want to hear the songs too.
So you have to be aware though...
That a lot of people...
That subscribe to singers...
Like singer and Vtubers...
They just... they... they listen to the songs.
They just hear and listen to the song.
And they like put it on repeat over and over and over and over again.
Um... but a lot of... but then there's a lot of Vtubers that got big!
From singing cover songs!
And it's good exposure!
If you have good cover songs!
There's so many like amazing...
Cover song singers...
That like... um... I love to listen to.
That are... that are like...
Big... big Vtubers now!
Like Amelie!
I have... I used to have... I have so many of her covers on my playlist!
Before like she became a Vtuber!
Before I became a Vtuber!
I would listen to her songs all the time!
On my playlist!
Cause I love cover songs in general!
I had so many like...
I would primarily just listen to cover singers.
Because I... I personally liked cover singers...
More than the original!
And... there's like so many of that in my playlist!
Uh... but yeah like I said just...
Make songs!
Alright!
Branding!
Okay this is like...
It's really...
Very like... in... like...
Ah!
Simple slide!
I feel like...
This slide in general...
There's not really like...
Much to say about it...
But like branding wise...
Like...
I would say...
100% this is what I believe in!
This is 100% what I believe in!
If you choose...
If you are an animal Vtuber...
It is the easiest when it comes to branding!
Because like...
Animal Vtubers...
Are like...
More recognizable than a human!
I would say that!
Because like...
There's like traits in there...
That are...
Um...
That...
That are there!
That makes you distinct...
From like...
Uh...
Other Vtubers!
Like you have like animal characteristics!
All the...
More...
More famous Vtubers...
Have like...
Some animal characteristic...
About them!
Because you can do many things about it!
You can like make them as like...
You know...
Their alternate form is the animal itself!
Or like...
You can make like...
Merch wise stuff!
Merch...
Merch and everything is like...
So good!
Like...
Regarding that!
And...
There's so many cat girls out there!
So like...
You have to be like...
What makes you more distinct from all the other cat girls?
You know?
You have to have something...
That makes you more distinct than the other cat girls!
You have to have like...
A...
A design trait!
A unique silhouette!
But you can't have too unique of a silhouette!
Because people...
Don't like it when it's too fucking complicated!
Um...
And then...
An average viewer needs to be able to pick you out...
Very easily!
So...
Branding is so very important!
This is why I've been like...
I think I...
I don't know...
I'm fucking...
I don't know what I'm gonna be doing!
For my skin suit...
I don't know man...
That's how I feel...
at the moment...
But my...
My new skin suit...
I don't know...
I just hope like...
My...
It works.
I hope it works.
It was so hard figuring out branding.
But like it's so important because like merch and stuff too.
If you want... okay long-term branding.
I would say long-term branding because like I know there's a lot of youtubers that like swap models or change their branding and stuff like that.
But like if you want to... if you like...
If you want to be more safe, you keep the same brand.
I say that as I'm getting a new skin suit, but this like this brand is like really old.
So like I have an excuse to upgrade.
Technically I sort of have an excuse to upgrade my branding because like...
This skin suit is very old.
To be fair, my original branding is a tomato.
So like...
It still works.
But like anyway, I would... to make it more simple and to make it like more... I guess like easier for you.
If you already have a noticeable brand, I would suggest highly to keep the same brand.
Because it's such a huge... that's why I'm scared.
This is why I'm personally scared.
I'm scared of my new skin suit.
Because when you change brands, you don't know if people are gonna stay.
Because maybe your old brand was like very already very recognizable and people hate change.
People really hate change.
And it also helps for the normies sphere.
Like average viewers outside of your community.
Average like from...
From the beginning.
Outside of your community.
That's like what's worrying.
Because it's like...
Oh you don't...
When you see them, you're like who is that?
You're like oh it's that person but they used to be this other person.
Why do they look different now?
Like stuff like that.
Marketing wise...
Marketing wise and like...
Uh...
Branding wise...
Keeping the same one.
I mean if you swap outfits, that's fine.
But I meant like a full revamp.
Is like...
That's why like companies keep the same brand.
Because consistency always is good.
Because if you have some...
You see that thing and you're like...
Oh I recognize them.
It's this person.
Um...
So...
So that's why like a lot of...
That's why like in companies people keep the same brand.
Um...
And I would think like if you want to keep the same brand for your future.
You stay the same brand.
Like I know like maybe you're like...
Oh but I want to be this next.
But like...
If you want to play it very safe.
Um...
If you want to...
Keep it very safe.
Um...
And you don't want to take risk.
This is like the best way to do it.
Like...
This is the best way.
Like if you don't want to take any risk.
And like you don't know if the viewership will stay the same.
Like type deal.
Okay.
Management and organization.
Alright.
Don't just hire anybody.
To be a manager.
It's so fucking stressful if you have the bad manager.
If you have like not a great manager.
If you want to hire somebody.
Do not hire close friends.
Never mix business and relationships together.
It's never good.
I would highly...
Highly suggest you do not hire close friends.
Or any friend.
Like...
Oh my god.
Do not hire close friends.
Okay guys.
Don't mix...
It's always a rule to never mix business.
With relations.
It's not great.
If you have the opportunity to hire a manager.
Just don't do that.
Hire somebody.
Look into someone with actual business experience.
This is when you are getting bigger.
As an indie.
Obviously when you start out.
You don't have managers.
You do this all yourself.
And so you have to...
If you are starting out.
Be sure to know how to read contracts.
Don't let people walk over you when you are negotiating.
And don't let people like...
Say...
Like...
Don't get scammed into signing a very predatory contract.
When it comes to like...
Sponsors and deals.
Because there is a lot of them out there.
So like...
You know.
You want to do like a brand deal or a sponsor.
You have to be sure you sign something that you really want to do.
And you don't get like...
Sucked into a contract that will fuck you over.
In terms of like...
Sponsors or merch and stuff like that.
And that's like...
As an indie.
You...
There is like a lot of those as an indie.
So like...
You have to be able to read these types of contracts if you don't have a manager.
Because...
But that is why you also get a manager to avoid these things.
A lot of emails that come to me.
Regarding like...
Opportunities and stuff.
My management reads those emails for me.
To make sure.
That like...
Before they...
The emails get to me.
It gets like...
Pre-reg by my management team.
So like...
I don't have to deal with the bad ones.
So I can just say yes or no on the good ones already.
That I get.
Like...
But yes.
Get a business lawyer.
If you want to be more serious.
Yeah.
They get screened.
The emails get screened.
So I'm sure that like...
I will not be getting the ones that...
That are like...
Predatory.
Um...
But yeah.
Anyway.
But yes.
Get a business lawyer.
To look through the contract.
To make sure everything is okay.
Um...
Have a business email.
And put it on your Twitter bio and streamer platform.
Don't think it's just gonna walk to you.
Have a business email out there.
Very direct.
It's there.
So you can get the emails instantly.
So like...
And also...
Um...
Make sure the business email is like a little bit professional.
Yeah.
Just a little bit professional.
I mean mine is Doki Kenrin.
But yes.
Also...
Yeah.
That stuff.
But also like...
Um...
Have a pitch deck made.
I think it's a very good investment.
If you want to chase sponsors.
If you want to like have sponsors like...
Um...
If you want to like approach sponsors and brand deals.
Have your own like portfolio and pitch deck made.
So like when you send it to them.
Like they can just see your analytics and everything.
So like...
Just make sure you have those together.
Also I saw like some people asking me like...
Oh what about like projects when you're organizing your project and stuff like that.
Like I talked about this earlier.
But like...
Um...
There's not really a whole...
Way I really do it.
That's like special.
At best...
I have a lot of multiple projects going on and stuff.
So...
Um...
I...
Because I have the opportunity to host and produce a lot of projects.
Um...
I...
I am able to...
Uh...
Delegate a project leader.
That runs the project.
Mostly like...
Everyth...
The project leader will talk to me about what's going on.
And then I also look into the server to see like what's going on as well.
I look into the server and be like...
Okay.
Seems like everything is going well.
But then the project leader will be responsible with making sure everything goes on track.
Everything is on track.
And everything is like...
Um...
Going well.
They obviously get paid more because they're the project leader.
Um...
Also like...
The way is that I give updates.
I give server updates.
And be like...
Oh here's the news.
What's going to happen.
And like...
Here are the new requirements.
Here's what I need.
Like I would give updates.
But the project leader makes sure everything goes well.
And keeps on track.
Also please...
Don't rely on Twitter DMs or Discord DMs.
Make a Discord server if you're doing a project.
You have to have...
Make sure everything...
Cause like...
Oh my god.
It's so confusing when you have so many DMs everywhere.
Have a Discord server.
Of...
So you can keep track of everything.
I will show you an example of my Discord servers.
Um...
Bam!
Here you go.
This is how my Discord server goes.
On the left is my...
Me and my management team.
On the right is my editing team.
And animators.
I also have animators too.
So this is how I organize my Discord server.
Um...
This is how the Discord server is done.
So you see like...
Here are all the important things that I have.
And then on the right you can see like...
Oh hey, for editing.
Here are the rules.
Here's my editing rules.
What I want the clips to have.
Um...
The general stuff where people want to talk in general.
Assets that I give them.
Regarding like PNGs.
Stuff like that.
Timestamp claims so the editors won't fucking like overlap each other with timestamps.
Like if they're clipping something.
From clip downloads.
So like...
When they're finished with a clip.
They just plop the links.
There.
They just plop the links there.
For me to download.
And then if they have any editing thing they need to ask.
They just put it there.
And then I have private channels with each individual editor.
So if they want to ask me anything privately.
That's not within like other...
If other...
If other people...
They don't want other people to see.
They talk to me in the private chat.
Everything is in like...
Is organized in a way so that um...
Is organized in a way so that like...
Uh...
In the...
Like...
It's just automated type deal.
It's just very organized.
And like...
I know where things are.
And...
And that's how I organize my stuff.
Cause I just...
We need to be sure.
That everything is in a way.
That I can easily like...
Look at it.
So like...
Especially like payment.
I tell them...
To tell me about payment.
In our private chat.
That people watch my videos.
This is so much fun.
That's my home, this is my This is...
Well, um...
Uh...
Well, yeah...
Everyone was like...
Ah...
Keeping the culture.
Keep the culture.
Keep them classy.
It's just better this way.
Shoutout to my management team for helping with the organization of the server itself.
Because it was not this neat before.
I gave a general template on how I want the server to be like.
And then they made it more organized.
So the left side is where me and my management team live.
The right side is the editing team.
Editing and animators.
I combined the Doki Bytes animators into the same Discord server.
So I don't have to worry about more than one.
Also the editors and the animators.
Don't overlap each other in terms of clip moments.
Because I have a rule.
And I said that I told them for the animators and editing team.
I do not want repeats.
I don't want repeats.
So like the animator and the editor teams have to be sure they don't animate or clip the same thing.
And that's why I combined them together.
So yeah.
So that is how like everything is done.
The reason we're not using Slack is because...
We can't be bothered.
That is why me and my management team are not using Slack.
So we're using Discord.
Alright.
General tips I've tried to follow.
These are my own way of streaming.
This is how I go about in terms of my own way of streaming.
First off.
Next.
A lot of people were saying like, oh how do you like deal with...
How do you deal with like...
Losing topics and stuff.
Like topics and stuff.
Like dead air.
I actually keep a list of topics I want to talk about on stream.
Every time I think of something I want to talk about, like...
If I have dead air.
If I think I have dead... I'm going to have dead air.
I have a channel where I type random topics throughout the day.
And then I would just pull that up if I have to.
I don't use it all the time.
If I think I have dead air, if I don't know what I'm going to talk about.
I would just pull it up and be like, oh yeah!
I'd be like, oh my god guys, I just remembered.
Did you guys know?
Blah blah blah blah blah.
Like, that's really it.
But I don't do that all the time.
I don't do that all the time.
I do it like, maybe like...
Once every two to three weeks.
Because I'm so used to streaming now.
This was like back then.
When I was first starting out.
And I was not very good at tangents.
In terms of like, I don't know what to talk about.
And...
I would make sure I write stuff down.
So I would write bullet points.
So I would write bear hibernation.
Stuff like that.
Just to make sure I remember.
So like, I would just write one bullet point.
And then I'd be like, I remember exactly the topic.
I'd be like, oh yeah!
Blah blah blah blah.
You know, stuff like that.
But it's basically for people who are just starting out.
And like, are not very good at talking.
And it's because I'm so used to talking now.
That like, I don't really use it anymore.
But I still put it...
I write it down out of habit.
Habit.
If you are a variety streamer.
This is what I do.
This is my own personal opinion.
I tend to keep long playthroughs.
3-4 streams max.
Because the longer the series.
The less viewership it's gonna get.
Which is because our attention is really fucked now.
This is for if you're a YouTuber.
If you're a Twitch streamer.
It's different.
It's like, really different.
Because like...
You know, like I said before.
People don't know when you're gonna stream whatever.
So they always show up.
And they'll be like, oh where are we gonna get today?
But if you're a YouTube streamer.
I usually keep it 3-4 streams.
Just because like, I know.
By the time it hits the 4th stream.
Like, the viewership.
Will decline even harder.
It's just gonna go lower and lower and lower.
So like, that is why I try to keep it.
3-4 streams.
So...
It's just so...
It's just to keep the attention span.
Like still there.
But this is what I do.
Like I said.
It's all like my personal experience.
If you wanna work with artists that are not English speaking.
Get a translator.
I've had this experience before.
I wanted to work with an artist that didn't speak English.
And I wrote in English.
But I also wrote my...
Translated...
Like my translation as well.
But then they were like, oh sorry.
We only work with people who speak it natively.
Like fluently.
Because they didn't wanna deal with like...
Issues.
If you didn't like the art and they don't understand what you want changed.
There's like translation issues.
And stuff like that.
DeepL is your friend.
If you wanna actually use a translator.
But I would highly suggest...
Talking...
With a translator.
Getting an actual translator.
That's fluent in the language.
Or...
Use DeepL.
But let the artist know that you're using a translation software.
Because you don't wanna like...
Lie and be like I'm actually fluent.
Or you're using a translation tool.
But yes.
I would highly suggest getting a translator.
To help you.
It is much better.
In the long run.
And it's a lot more convenient for you.
Like to get what you want.
But...
Have a consistent time block.
People love consistency.
People love...
You being consistent.
That is why I have two set time blocks.
12.30 pm PST.
And 5 pm PST.
That is my time block.
And that's what people know.
People know that you stream around those times.
Consistency is key.
Always have a dedicated time block.
For whatever you stream.
Don't stream random hours all the time.
Because your audience will not know what to do.
They'll be like what the fuck.
What time do I show up?
I don't know.
They're always different.
Get a consistent time block.
Even on Twitch.
The thing about Twitch is that even if they don't have a set...
A set plan.
They are consistent.
With what time they stream at.
So like...
Always be consistent.
It's always the key.
Have mods.
Don't self moderate.
It's not great.
And have them be like...
Mostly silent.
But like...
If they want to interject they can.
We don't want a mod to spam the chat.
Just be like...
My mods...
I have 3 mods working in this chat.
Um...
And like...
They all have second accounts.
Their mod account is actually...
Their second account.
So like...
The real mods...
The real accounts...
Is among you.
It could be any of you guys.
So they don't have to...
They don't have to worry.
They can actually talk to you guys.
Uh...
It could be any of you guys.
So they have 2 accounts.
One for moderating.
And one to chat.
Like...
Be just like a regular dragoon.
I'm the mod smile.
Message received.
Have all your mods be...
Silently.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But yes.
I have them mostly silent.
Because I don't want to cause any issues.
And that is why...
They are mostly silent.
Um...
Also...
Please make a business paypal.
And set up a business account.
Long run.
If you want to make this a long term career.
It would be so good for you.
Just remember that.
Please remember to set everything up as a business.
Because this is your career now.
If this is what you want to do as a career.
So...
Uh...
So yeah.
That is basically one of my general tips to follow.
If you want to...
If you want to see what is going on behind my fucking brain.
Alright.
Merch.
Very important as an indie.
I would say...
Merch.
I did not realize how much merch matters.
Until recently.
Like for an indie.
And it is like...
A lot of income can come from merch.
And...
Um...
Basically...
I...
If you want to do your own merch.
If you want to handle the whole merch yourself.
And not want to look at distributors.
Alibaba is your friend.
Alibaba is a great website to look for manufacturers.
It is a good manufacturer website.
Um...
The thing is...
When you are looking...
When you are researching manufacturers yourself.
You have to research the samples.
And...
You have to look at like...
Samples.
And like...
Uh...
What else is there?
And...
Oh fuck.
Okay.
I don't remember.
And you have to like...
Um...
There is other manufacturer websites to look at.
There is a lot of them.
And there is like ones in like...
America and stuff like that.
Ones in like Canada.
Some in Japan and stuff like that.
A lot of them are like...
On websites.
Similar to like...
Uh...
Different type.
There is like lots of websites...
For this too.
Um...
The thing is...
It's really hard to find a manufacturer...
That you want to work with.
Because you have to look at sample size.
You have to look at samples...
And like make sure you are not getting scammed.
Of course.
Not getting scammed.
And the quality is what you want.
Obviously the more you pay...
For a manufacturer...
The more expensive...
The more expensive things are gonna get...
To be made.
And the more expensive...
Things are gonna get to be sold.
But the quality is a lot better.
Um...
So...
You have to be able to pick and choose.
Uh...
You have to be able to like...
Make sure that is what you want to work with.
Uh...
Anyway...
Making your own merch.
I was very luckily...
I was an artist ally.
I did artist ally a lot.
And I sold art.
Um... at conventions.
So there is a lot of things you can do to make your own merch.
Yay!
Like these are things...
You can do yourself.
You don't have to get a manufacturer.
You can just do this yourself as a smaller indie.
And still have merch for your fans.
Button makers.
They are 150 to 300 US dollars.
Including the materials.
So like...
It's just a button press.
You...
You print out the artwork you want to make into a button.
And then...
You commission an artist to make a button design.
And then you print it out.
That's it.
And then you fucking...
Done.
And that's how you make a button.
You can sell them for like 2 to 4 dollars.
Depending on how big the button is.
And then...
You can make the eventsment back.
Printing your own stickers.
Sticker paper.
That's a thing.
Sticker papers are a thing.
Or...
You can fucking...
There's like local printing shops that make stickers.
That you can just like...
You know...
Order online or order like from a shop.
From your local mom and pop shop.
Or like...
I don't know...
Walmart.
I used to cut my own stickers when I first started out in artist alley.
And I still made money from that.
And they're good and...
They make money.
And then printing your own...
Post-art cards and prints at a local store.
That works.
You don't have to worry.
It's like...
You can do that as your own merch.
Anyway...
If you're gonna work with distributors...
Obviously they're gonna take a cut of your money.
Because you're working with them.
They're gonna be like...
Doing the whole thing for you.
Like the researching manufacturers.
Um...
You know...
Researching manufacturers and...
Making sure like the quality and stuff like that.
But...
You gotta research and read the contract very thoroughly.
I would highly suggest...
Not going with one that's a startup.
Because like...
For distributors.
And ones that have experience distributing stuff.
Because...
It's out of your hands.
When...
Because you're not part of the process.
And...
Honestly it's better to...
Work with somebody that has experience...
Distributing stuff.
Because shipping things is a lot of work.
I've done shipping...
I ship stuff myself.
And it's a lot of work.
And it's not that easy.
I run my own...
Thing all by myself.
It doesn't mean I'm gonna do that forever though.
It doesn't mean.
And I'm not...
And I'm like very open to like...
Maybe if I find a distributor I'd like...
I can give them a percentage cut.
I do it myself because I wanna keep majority of the earnings.
Um...
Because I know how to do it.
And I have experience doing it.
And that is why I handle...
I handle like everything myself regarding merch.
I know other...
Vtubers that do it as well.
Not just me.
Because I've talked to...
I recently was talking to somebody regarding merch stuff.
Because we were like exchanging our...
Our manufacturers.
We were exchanging like...
Info of each other and stuff.
Regarding like...
Manufacturers and like...
Um...
Oh like...
What's the word?
Oh... fuck.
Just being like...
Oh yeah.
You do...
What's this?
Well I wanna try producing this later too.
So then we were exchanging information with each other.
So we can build up our knowledge and stuff.
Uh... so that's like...
That's a good thing.
If you have like friends with somebody that also makes merch.
Uh... talk to them about it.
And like... like exchange information with each other.
That's why I don't like gate keeping information.
I like be like...
Oh yeah I'm planning on doing this.
Like oh what are you gonna be doing?
And stuff like that.
And then be like...
Oh yeah I wanna look for a manufacturer that does this as well.
And stuff like that.
Um...
So that's what...
That's what I try to do.
I realized...
I realized I forgot a slide.
So...
Let me download this slide.
They're all PNGs.
I realized I forgot...
A slide real quick.
Cause that sort of fits the topic that I wanna talk about.
Let me add this in.
But this one is about networking and collaboration.
Cause like the other stuff will not be as...
The other stuff wouldn't make sense if I go down there.
So let me add that slide real quick.
Boop!
Add files.
Where did I download it?
Okay let's see.
I think it's...
Is this collab and networking?
I think this is.
Alright.
Alright let me...
Let me push this slide up higher.
Wooo!
Alright!
Networking and collabs!
There we go.
Alright!
Networking and collabs.
Balance your schedule!
I talked about this before.
But please!
Do not make it mostly collabs.
It should be...
Collab streams...
Should not be more than solo streams.
Because if you spend too many collabs...
Per week...
Especially when you're just starting out...
Then you're not building a fan base.
And community that's...
And the community that's there for you.
You have...
You want to have viewers that want to watch you.
So you don't want to like...
Just...
Have mostly collabs.
Because people would be like...
I just want to watch them interact with this streamer instead.
Instead of actually watching for you.
So you have to have a healthy balance.
I do 1-2 collabs per week.
Because if I have lots of collabs going on...
I also try to balance it more with solo streams.
Because I know...
My dragoons...
They also want some personal dragoon time.
They want me to interact with the chat.
And that's why...
They want to have an identity.
You don't want to be the collabber.
You don't want that to be your identity.
You just collab.
You don't have solo content.
You want to have personal content.
So people will know your personality.
So like I said...
Don't rely too much on collabs.
Like I said...
If you're relying too much on collabs...
you're basically giving yourself a crutch.
And you have a harder time...
develping your personality and presence.
It also has...
YouTube...
It gives more opportunities for dead subs and followers.
You don't want that people who follow you..
Because you collab with this one person.
They want them to follow you because...
They enjoyed that experience.
And...
They want to watch more of you.
This is why a lot of collab channels die so fast.
There is a...
You can look at this example with Fleshtubers.
A lot of Fleshtubers, they like become big because of the group they are with.
Because they have like a YouTube group.
But as soon as that YouTube group falls apart, their channel dies.
Because the viewers, they only want to watch that stream, that channel, for the group they are in.
Not because of the people they are.
They're like, oh my friend group experience.
No!
Like, that shit sucks.
Because they're like, no I watched you because I wanted to have that friend group experience.
So I can live vicariously through this friend group.
And then now that you don't have that friend group, it's not as fun.
I used to watch the creatures.
I live vicariously through the creatures.
And like, that's the thing.
Especially like when they started going their separate ways.
They didn't have really an identity beyond that.
They didn't have the identity.
Like, it was just like, it was literally like the friend group was gone.
But you know, there's like so many experiences.
You can fucking look at Minecraft and like, uh, what is it?
Quibblequap or whatever.
Like shit like that.
Like, you can't be just the friend group.
You have to be your own.
You have to be your own individual.
Um...
Alright.
How to be good at collabs.
This is my...
My opinion.
But there's two roles in a collab.
This is how I see it.
The support and the leader.
So the support is obviously like, you look at it as a comedy duo.
But it can be like a group thing too.
So...
So you can have the straight man and the leader.
Or like the...
The dumb one.
Or the chaotic one.
Or the one with the comedy.
You need someone to react and the other one to be there.
Someone to bring the reaction and stuff.
Um...
And so...
Or you can be both.
One of the strongest skills you can have is to be both of them.
And I think I personally, I can be both.
I can be a reactor.
If I'm in a group that is way too chaotic.
I can be the straight man.
If I need it to be.
I can be the reactor.
Like the one that tries to be the sane one.
In the group.
Like it is possible.
If you can have the skillset to be both.
You are, you can be a really good content creator.
Because you're not locked into...
You're not locked into a group.
In a way.
You're not locked into certain people you can collab with.
And that is what makes a very strong collab.
So you don't want a whole group filled with supporters.
Like you know, all the people who can only do you support.
You don't want a full group of chaotic people.
Because it will be way too much.
You need to be able to have a healthy balance.
This is what I look into when collabs.
I try to find a healthy balance of people that would balance...
That would like... that would be good foils to each other.
Sometimes I look at... I try to min-max collab groups in the past.
I have done that.
Sometimes they're random.
It depends on what kind of collab I'm planning.
I have min-max collabs before in the past.
And I have like done random people.
It really depends on like how you want this collaboration to be like.
Because I can... I... the thing is...
I have the... I have the...
I guess like...
I have like the opportunity to be able to do random.
Because I can do both roles.
I can be a support and a leader.
I can be like... I can do both like the...
I can do both like...
Oh, the chaotic role.
The... the say random shit role.
Or I can be there to react and stuff.
And to be able to like...
To be able to like, you know, make it so like, you know...
I'm enabling whoever is the leader.
I'm making sure I'm enabling the leader.
I'm enabling their content to be bigger than what it was.
Like they would say something and I will make it...
Make it like more funny.
And I'll make it more like...
Oh chaotic or something.
Like stuff like that.
And...
That is like what makes a good collab.
And that's how you organize.
When I'm at min-maxing, I make sure I choose like...
There's some collabs I will purposely pick regarding like collab partners.
Because I know the collab...
That comes out of it will be really good content.
Because I know the people in that group like will reflect really...
Will like foil each other really well.
Like they'll like compliment each other really well.
And I've done that before.
I've also done random people.
Like being who's free.
Like I've done both.
It really depends on like...
It really depends on like how you want to see the collab.
Anyway...
So that is like my like ideology when it comes to setting up these collabs.
Socialize!
I hate it but...
Always remember the people who were there for you.
So...
Return favors and offer opportunities back to other people.
Who were there for you or who have done the same to you.
If you...
Like I've done this before.
If I have an extra invite to something.
I would give this invite to somebody that I knew was there for me.
Or like that I knew...
That I knew would benefit from.
Like I would be like...
Oh hey!
You were there for me.
I have an invite to this thing.
Do you want to do it?
Because I know they're there for me.
I know that if something happens.
If something comes up.
You'll have something to return back.
They'll be like...
Oh hey!
Like...
This person was there for me.
So I'll be there for you.
Like just make sure you always remember the people.
Who...
Who like...
Returned favors or did you a favor.
You always remember that.
And it's like paying it forward.
So it's always good for you long run.
To be able to like remember these things.
And...
The worst people can say is no.
Like I said.
Always shoot your shot.
The worst is they ghost you or they say no.
You have to get used to rejection.
It's happened a lot.
I've ghosted people a lot because I get overwhelmed.
So I'm like...
Sometimes people ghost you not because they didn't want...
They didn't want to work with you.
It's because they're so fucking busy.
And that has happened to me.
I've ghosted people because I was so fucking busy.
And I was so very overwhelmed.
I've been overwhelmed a lot.
And so like it's very common for me to be super overwhelmed.
And not like reply back instantly.
I've had moments where I'd be like...
I'm so sorry for taking a month to reply.
Everything was so overwhelming.
I'm sorry.
And then...
And so...
It's understandable.
So like...
Just be aware.
That these things happen.
And a lot of content creators like have their own lives.
And like maybe, they don't want to collab.
And then they just don't want to say no.
You gotta live with it.
If you're in content creation.
You gotta live with these things.
Like...
You gotta like.
You just gotta deal with it.
You want this to be your job.
This is...
This really it.
Can I say...
Okay, what else?
What else?
Oh yeah, websites and resources!
Alright, so here are some really good websites and resources for you to use for streaming.
There's Booth, there's Nizima.
I don't know if I'm pronouncing it right, I'm so sorry.
I don't even think I should pronounce it because I know I'm going to butcher it.
So, the four things I listed, they're really good resource websites.
Booth, the first two, they're really good for assets and backgrounds and like VTuber models or skin suits.
All of that.
The last two are really good for like also for assets and backgrounds and like copyright-free shit.
Like, they're... those are really good.
Like, I would highly suggest looking at these websites for like just information you need, like graphics and stuff like that.
Or like assets.
You don't want to pay?
A lot of the things on there are free!
That's the best part!
A lot of there is for free!
Care of fun!
It's really good for karaoke or singing.
Like, you're worried about like copyright claims and stuff like that.
I highly suggest using care of fun!
Because like, they have like...
Usually, if you use care of fun stuff, you don't have to worry about copyright things.
Because like, they're all like...
It's a... there's a subscription fee.
It's a subscription fee though.
It's like $50, I think, a month.
But if you're like a regular singer or like you like to do karaoke, this is a good investment for the future.
And then, Shoost?
Shoost?
I don't know.
They're like really good like...
You have to do Patreon pledge stuff.
But they're really good for like...
Like, you know like those like really...
Pretty...
Immersive like...
Settings and stuff where like the light at the background actually looks like it connects with the...
With the Vtuber.
That's it!
That's the thing.
It's just really good atmospheric stuff to use when you're streaming.
So that's what they use.
So these are really all really good websites and resources.
If you really wanna look for free things, you don't wanna spend money...
I highly...
This glasses?
Free!
I literally look for Vtuber glasses asset.
If you really wanna find free stuff...
These are really good places to like look at if you want free things.
Okay, mental health care.
I will admit I am not the person to go to advice for this.
Because I still battle with it frequently.
If you want to be a content creator or a Vtuber...
You have to know you're so fucked when it comes to mental health.
There's no one that's okay.
You have to be aware that you're gonna go through some mental health shit.
It could be like little bit.
It doesn't have to be like...
It doesn't have to be like really bad.
But you will feel it.
If you wanna be a content creator or like anything to do with making content on the internet.
You will not have like the most positive mental health experience.
It's all about mitigating it.
Just make sure you have a support system that is outside of content creation.
Because if you live... if you have like a support system that's within content creation.
You're just in a fucking echo chamber of like some things.
So you only like an outside perspective.
You really need very thick skin to be able to like do this as a career.
Like especially like you're gonna deal with so many things.
Like you're gonna deal with a lot of stuff.
So you really need thick skin.
And even if you have thick skin.
You're still gonna go through some mental health shit.
Um... on the internet.
Because your numbers will affect...
You can say numbers will affect you cause you don't wanna fucking fail.
Like you know...
Of course you'll be like I'm trying to have better numbers.
Because I wanna have a successful career.
Like you don't... you still have to pay attention to it.
So it's still gonna affect you.
So... um...
You just have to be able to have a good support system outside of just content creation.
And do stuff outside every once in a while.
Like um...
So... just be able to like handle that.
Like you have the risk for being a fucking content creator.
Is that...
It's not a very mentally healthy thing.
Like...
Being an entertainer is not just like on the internet.
You can look at like Hollywood actors.
Those people are not okay.
Hollywood actors, TV actors, celebrities outside of fucking the internet.
They are not okay as well.
If you're in the entertainment business.
Like you're... you're... you're...
You're gonna have to go through some shit.
Like...
So you have to be aware.
And that is like the biggest risk you have to take.
You just have to remember that.
Alright.
Anyway...
I'm gonna look at questions on Twitter now.
To see if there is anything that I can...
I'm gonna look at any of the questions I have on Twitter.
If there is anything I wanna answer.
But that is basically...
That is basically like all I have written down for myself to talk to you guys about.
So I hope like all the stuff I have...
All the stuff I have...
Also I'll do like... I'll put like questions from chat as well.
All the stuff I have written down.
I hope the slides itself has been very informative chat.
I hope they have been very informative.
And that it has like helped you guys figure out like...
Give you advice and tips on how to go through like content creation and VTubing in general.
I will be taking questions now from...
I'll be looking at the Twitter thread that I made regarding if anybody had questions before I made this stream.
As well as taking questions from chat.
I hope it assists you regarding if you want a VTuber career in content creation.
And how to game the algorithm.
Okay, so I have this one question that I saw.
And one of them was like...
How do you manage your energy levels and social battery when it comes to networking, creating video content, streaming with your VTuber skin suit, and responding to a bunch of brand deals or collabs?
How do you keep the momentum going during all that work?
Well...
All my energy is mostly on streaming.
That's why when I say off stream, I'm like really different.
It's because...
I've normally put all my energy within streaming.
And like...
And then I go to power save mode the moment after.
Streaming is also like sort of an escape for me.
It's not very healthy.
But like for me...
I...
I like to stream because it is like...
I very much enjoy streaming.
And it is like my way of escaping work.
Because my work is...
Off stream.
My work is off stream at the moment.
So...
That is why I love streaming.
That's how I keep my energy.
All my energy is streaming.
And I do power save after streaming.
I have a management team that helps me with brand deals.
At best, like I would look through the details of stuff that got screened.
And filter out.
And then...
And then when it comes to networking.
I take that really slow at the moment.
Networking is the thing I'm like really slow on.
Because right now I am focused on stabilizing myself.
I am trying to make sure I'm more stabilized in my career.
Because like I said like...
My career just started out of a sudden as an indie.
And I'm still at the point where I'm still trying to stabilize.
There's a lot of groundwork that we have to make.
And we're still making that groundwork.
And there's a lot of things I haven't announced yet.
There's so many things I haven't announced yet.
Regarding like...
Like you know future sponsors.
Future brand deals.
There's so many things I haven't yet been able to announce.
Because we're still like...
Like stabilizing.
We're still establishing things.
But we're slowly getting there.
So that is really how...
How my life is at right now.
Um...
Okay.
Uh...
Thank you.
Do you have a workout routine?
Or do you sustain through pure mental fortitude and caffeine?
That's the thing.
Um...
Right now...
I haven't really had a really decent workout routine at the moment.
Um...
Because I'm not stabilized at the moment.
Before in the past, I did.
I have a treadmill in my room.
But because like...
You have to take some cuts.
In terms of like your routine.
And that is sadly one of the things I had to take a cut on.
I don't normally drink caffeine.
But I have drank caffeine.
At least like once or twice a week.
Uh...
I have taken...
Drink...
Drank some caffeine once or twice a week.
And um...
And because I really need it.
Like...
I...
There's been a lot of stuff.
Um...
That I have to do.
And I...
Sometimes I get really tired after a while.
And um...
I have...
Unfortunately that is like one of the things I have to do.
I have to take caffeine now.
Because it's been like real...
A lot of work.
To stay like...
Uh...
Stay up.
I only drink caffeine...
Off stream.
I don't do it on stream.
I know a lot of people think I'm like super energetic.
Or like...
Um...
I take something when I'm streaming.
I do not drink any type of caffeine.
I drink water.
I just drink water when I'm streaming.
Off stream.
I actually drink like tea.
Like green tea or coffee.
Just to be like...
Uh...
Just to like survive.
If I have a stream at like really late.
I would drink coffee.
I would drink coffee if I have a stream really fucking late.
Because like...
You know...
I'm fucking exhausted.
It's like 3 in the morning.
So of course I'm gonna drink coffee.
To just survive.
Hahaha.
Uh...
Man, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
What should I do with my favorite YouTuber suddenly lasts a lot out of nowhere?
Is that the side?
Hahaha.
No comment.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Malcolm.
How do you find games?
What games are popular?
Are there any tools do you use for this?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Very easy.
You go on Steam.
You go to...
Recently released.
Or upcoming games.
Recently released on Steam.
You look at the reviews.
If a new game gets like more than 700 plus reviews.
This is how I found pineapple on pizza by the way.
I was like the first one to stream pineapple on pizza.
Because I literally looked at the reviews.
And I was like this game came out yesterday.
Like I'll be like this game came out yesterday.
It has a thousand reviews.
What the fuck?
And then I streamed it.
And that's how I found out.
I was one of the first one to stream it.
I saw like there were a thousand reviews with a game that just came out yesterday.
And then I just streamed it because I was like clearly this is going to be a meta game.
Clearly this game is going to be popular.
And it was like basically like you just like look at Steam.
Like if you look at the game reviews.
If it's like if there's like I said if if a game on Steam recently released has more than like 500 plus reviews.
Then most likely it is going to be like a meta game.
It's going to be a meta stream.
You can also look at upcoming releases and just judge by the upcoming releases.
Another way is to I said this before but you look at Twitch and see what's the most.
Like you go at Twitch and see like what's popular.
You go to browse and then categories and then bam.
You see like if you see a stream of a game that's like oh I've never seen this before.
I've never seen this game before.
What the fuck?
And then you click on it and you're like oh that's a new stream meta.
The Twitch front page is basically a story of like what's meta.
You can also follow some big content creators.
Like these content creators they always follow meta.
Which is like Moist Critical.
Let's see Moist Critical follows Twitch meta.
Not Twitch meta.
Follows streamer meta very well.
He follows streamer meta in terms of games really really well.
And I would like sometimes like I think I saw I think I saw supermarket simulator.
No not from him.
I saw it somewhere else.
I don't remember who I don't remember who I saw that was streaming supermarket simulator.
And I I knew that like I knew that someone was streaming it and I knew that was going to be that's the stream meta.
And that's why I put it on my schedule because I saw it somebody stream it and I was like oh my God.
I'm going to stream it because I was like wait this is the next stream game.
And that's why.
That's why I streamed it.
I think I'm trying to think what sure for I think so.
Whenever sure for gets addicted to a new game.
I knew it's it's a good game.
Ludwig is also a good stream meta follower.
Ludwig follows meta really well.
Let's see.
What else?
So thank you for super chat.
Thank you.
You mentioned making merch is very important for income for how much does it cost usually commissioned art for merchandise.
And it was super chat.
Thank you.
That really depends on what kind of merch you want to you want to make.
Obviously I gave some cheap options.
I was think like acrylic stands and acrylic stands pins stickers.
Prince.
They are like the most convenient ones and the easiest to make because you can't fuck it up.
You can't fuck up stickers.
You can't fuck up acrylic stands.
You can't fuck up like Prince and stuff like that.
Those are like the easiest to make and like you don't have to worry about grabbing samples and stuff like that.
The more complicated the merch the more oh and keychains.
Yes.
And keychains the more complicated the merch the harder is to grab like.
To grab like merch that's not fucked up.
You know like you know you're like a manufacturer sent you merch.
It's like you might get more like duds than you do like actual like quality quality that you can send out to people.
Even enamel pins and enamel pins.
Oh my God.
You have to find a really good manufacturer for pins like enamel pins because like you can fuck that up so easily.
I've had one time where I got a manufacturer that like sent me like.
The quality control for that is so hard to manage because they would send me like.
I don't I never worked with that one again.
But they sent me like a thousand pins or something.
And like I think like 200 of them were like duds.
Like there was like markings on it that I had to clean myself.
And like at the but even then I didn't I couldn't get like the scratch marks and stuff out of it.
There's like and I had to like sell it as a bargain price and stuff because it's like it's so hard.
That's why it's like enamel pins are like.
Some of the riskiest for quality control.
Anything beyond like keychain stickers pin like buttons like like the buttons and acrylic stands are really hard to get quality control.
Right?
So you guys gotta be like really careful for stuff like that.
And we're writing art.
Like I said, it depends on who you want to Commission depends on each artist has his own rates.
So I can't give you an estimate.
There's some artists that charges a lot.
There's some artists that don't.
It really depends on the estimate.
Some artists will charge a commercial price.
Some won't just have to it's basically who you want to Commission.
Oh many.
Thank you.
Let's super chat.
What's the best way to announce a big project event so that you can receive the most engagement on stream live?
That's really the best way if you're a streamer on stream live and now so you don't say anything about what the thing is.
You say special announcement special event.
And then you review.
You reveal it on stream because and you reveal the participants on stream.
You don't reveal it on Twitter or like social media first.
You reveal it on stream because people want to know who's participating.
So you announce it on stream one by one because it gets bring it builds.
It builds up like anticipation and stuff.
And you're like, oh and you're like, oh who's going to be next?
Whoa.
So announcing any you announce things live.
Not via social media unless it's like a tournament invite then like you can't really announce that live.
Yeah, you it's like you see like everybody always does this.
Oh, I'm doing this thing.
Wait until the very end you wait like oh if you want to hear what the announcement is you wait until the very end because you make all the viewers wait until the very end.
They show come to watch you do a regular stream.
If it's a regular stream with announced tacked on the end.
It makes it.
The viewers stay until the very end because they want to know what the announcement is.
So that's what like that's what people usually do.
That's the meta that what brings in all the engagements for your stream.
Let's see.
Let's see what to do here.
Okay.
Uh, direct thing in the super chat thing.
Thank you.
So you talk.
How do you go about learning a language becoming some influence requires years?
Isn't it?
You would know since you are you okay.
You want to learn languages get a tutor get a teacher the best because the best way to learn a language is being able to speak that language with somebody else and the easiest way to do that is having a tutor.
Having a teacher or a friend.
To help you with your studies because if you just read and write your you're not learning as fast as like speaking the language with somebody.
So you have to always be able to commute.
You have to become able to communicate with somebody to be able to to be able to build up your language learning and like talk speaking the language helps you learn so much like you just have to get a tutor.
You can grab like so many resources like, you know, I have a like lots of books and everything and like just study the book.
But if you don't speak that language regularly, then it won't help you.
Duolingo is not a good enough way to learn language.
Duolingo is like substitute.
You can use it as an extra learning but it's not the main thing you use for learning.
You have to have other ways to learn.
You can't just rely on Duolingo.
Yeah.
Thank you.
The super chat.
Hearing everything you have to say made me realize that I'm better off pursuing content creation as a hobby rather than a job.
Thank you.
The super chat.
The thing is a lot of content creators start off as a hobby because it's not stable.
It's not a stable job and it's all about luck.
But it's all about trying to maximize your luck as well.
I would say oh yeah, someone says watch streams.
Yes.
If you want to get better watch streams in that language.
Which you're trying to learn.
I improved a lot in my Cantonese and my Mandarin because I when I lived in Asia, I would only watch the TV was playing and then I would like watch like shows like shows in that language because like, you know, the TV was on I had nothing to do and I was I couldn't play on my PC.
So I would just sit there and just watch and I got better.
I got better in my listening skills.
I've got better my listening skills and my speaking skills.
So I highly recommend watching streams in that language and you're going to slowly pick up the language as well.
If you're learning already, if you're learning already, it helps improve your learning.
It helps improve it a lot.
But yes, like I said content creation.
A lot of people start out as a hobby.
If it's best if you start out with having a as like a as like an extra income and not like, you know, go full in because like, you know, you always...
You need to have a good income.
You need a backup plan.
You always need to have a backup plan, you know, so like a lot of people start off content creation as a hobby and then later on when it gets more successful, you fold like you start investing more into it.
And then when you make enough money, you can like, you know, fully commit to it.
And that's like the safest way.
I think if you want to go safe, I would say like always have a backup plan because you don't don't quit your day job.
Yeah, always like make sure you have.
Something in the backup just in case.
Let's see.
What else?
How much do I have?
Let's see.
Bolly think of a super chat thing.
You thank you.
I made a plushy of my VTuber and my subs want to buy it $35 plus 122 for international shipping.
That is way too much.
How big is the plushy?
That is way too much for a plushy.
It also, where do you live without doxing yourself?
Without doxing yourself like that is honestly way too much for shipping.
It really depends on like how much the oh, okay.
How much the how big the plushy is too.
Because at that point.
That is way too expensive, especially like if it's an NA and plushy should not be that expensive for shipping.
I don't know overseas shipping.
I don't know like how bad shipping is in other countries, but like I know for NA that's way too expensive for international and at that point.
It's just so much easier to just find a distributor because distributors help if you're if the.
Plushy is like manufactured.
Not by you.
If you're not the one that made that plushy, then like at that point getting distributor helps with that.
But I feel like I feel like a hundred and twenty-two dollars in general is way too much for for from what I'm seeing my experience.
I know like in different countries it really depends on like how much shipping is in different countries.
And that's why some countries, some companies have distributors in like cheaper places.
Like not cheaper places, in like in that place.
Like the distributor would be like you know they want to distribute stuff in America.
But the company is in Japan.
They will buy a warehouse.
They would have a warehouse in America for cheaper shipping.
Stuff like that.
Just to help with shipping and stuff.
And that's why people find distributors because to help with shipping.
Let's see...
I'm trying to see what else to answer.
Nyanah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi Doki, my question is how to smoothly approach other streamers to make genuine connections?
Twitter and their chat.
A lot of my friends I've made before I you know started being a serious Vtuber.
Like before the friends I made like two years.
Like friends I made before I started being serious Vtubing two years ago.
It was from Twitter and Twitch chat.
Like I was a Twitch chat.
And I would like hang out.
I would raid them.
I would raid them and then a lot of them are artists too.
A lot of the friends I made because I was an artist Vtuber.
So I would draw a lot.
And like you know I just like do art streams and everything.
So and because of that I made friends by raiding other Twitch streamers.
And also like talking to them on Twitter and interacting with them.
And then they'll like tweet something.
Like they'll tweet art and I'm like oh my god I love your art.
And stuff like that.
And I would like give them like signal boosts them if they want.
That they have like they tweet something.
I would like boost their tweets and stuff by retweeting it.
And like you know talk to them on Discord and talk to them on Twitch.
And like play games with them on stream.
Like it's all about just like being consistent and stuff like that.
Obviously I am a lot more busy now.
I'm not a lot more busy now.
So I don't have that you know I don't have time to really like do that anymore.
And now I just like you know I it's a whole harder for me to make more friends.
Just because I have a lot of stuff going on.
And I have to make sure I can balance my schedule and stuff like that.
But back then.
Back then I would just you know just hang out and talk to them.
And just raid them.
And raid their streams.
And because I wanted to like know them more.
Uh...
Let's see.
Big boy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi Doki.
Quick question.
Is it possible for me to start streaming as a hobby despite having...
Yes!
You can have any time block.
I used to be a degen streamer.
I wouldn't start my stream when I was a Twitch streamer.
I would stream at 9pm.
And I had an audience for 9pm streams.
Sometimes I stream at 1am.
And I had an audience for that time.
I was known as the degen hour streamer.
Like if people were up in degen hours time.
Or people on the other side of the world.
Wanted an English speaking streamer to watch.
I was there for them.
But yes.
It doesn't matter.
Any time is possible.
You don't have to worry.
Any time is...
You just stream.
Like just stream.
If you have a...
A really bad...
Work hours schedule.
Just make that your consistent stream hours.
There is an audience base somewhere for it.
Ummm...
Let's see.
Uhh...
How do you find collabs as a small streamer?
Literally little friends, connection and networking.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I would suggest...
Find other people...
Around your...
Viewer level.
And just interact with them.
They want connections too.
As an indie.
That's the biggest thing as an indie.
We all want to find a group.
That's why I'm doing so many collabs.
Because I'm trying to find a consistent group.
To hang out with.
To see who I groove with the most.
So I'm trying to collab with like...
A bunch of people from different areas.
To like...
Meet new people.
Just want to have a...
Consistent group of people to just hit up to...
Do games with.
And umm...
Just reach out.
Like the biggest hurdle...
Is just reaching out to people.
And I'm pretty sure...
Those people who are around your range...
They want more friends too.
They want more connections.
They want to find new vtubers, new friends.
But never forget...
Who was there for you.
Never forget.
There's a lot of people that I used to know...
That was like around my view count...
When I was like a lot smaller.
And then umm...
They're now really big streamers.
You don't know.
Just never forget what they did for you.
And what you did for them.
So umm...
You always just remember that like...
Umm...
Just who stuck out for you.
And who like was there.
Just remember that.
And just reach out to people...
Around your similar range.
Because I'm pretty sure...
They're also looking for friends.
They're also looking for people to play with.
That's one of the hardest parts in indie.
People just...
And why people want to join a community.
They want to have...
Sorry, why people want to join a company.
They want to have a community.
That they can just hit up on.
And bam!
Easy.
They just want a community.
Umm...
Let's see.
Thanks.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
How do you come up with good jokes on the spot and chat entertain?
So is it wise to separate content like music and game on different channels?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Umm...
How do I come up with good jokes on the spot and chat...
That's just a talent.
Like...
I can't...
I can't give advice on that.
Because I'm not good at it.
I naturally just had that.
As a skill.
For me.
So like... I'm sorry.
I unfortunately can't give you advice on how to come up with good jokes on the spot.
And like chat entertain is just...
For chat entertainment...
Don't...
Don't bash something over and over again.
Don't beat up a dead horse.
That's really it.
Like chat entertainment...
As long as you don't beat a dead horse.
And like keep bringing up something over and over and over again.
Repetitively.
That's like the best advice I can give you.
Like...
There are moments where like some jokes would come up that I would say.
That became like memes.
And like phrases that were like...
My chat would consistently bring up.
But I wouldn't say it that often.
I would say it like...
Or I would never say it ever again.
I say this phrase once and then...
It's forever.
It's like the...
The chat loves it so much.
They always remember it.
I said it once.
On one stream.
And then...
But it was my identity.
And like...
The thing is you have to know when...
To give the joke back.
Or like...
Or when to like...
Stop a joke.
Because you have to make it so that the chat doesn't get tired of it.
Because you don't overkill it.
Like...
As long as the chat is entertaining themselves.
That's all that matters.
And regarding like...
How do I come up with these jokes on the spot.
I think you guys should know.
When I first started streaming.
I wasn't...
I got peer pressure to stream.
I...
Like...
I didn't stream because I wanted to be a streamer.
This is a little lore.
I don't know if I told this before.
I'm pretty sure I have.
Basically I got discovered in Overwatch.
And like...
Because...
I was using...
Voice chat to like...
Play Overwatch.
And I had a streamer in my game.
And then later on I became friends.
With some streamers.
Who played Overwatch.
Like they was all high ranked Overwatch.
And...
And then like they told me to start streaming.
And so...
They were like...
I'm very entertaining.
Because I would say like random shit.
Like these are like big Overwatch content creators.
At that time too.
And like I would say like...
Something that would be funny.
And then like they would be like...
Wait you should like stream.
You can be a really good...
You're really entertaining.
Like you're really entertaining off stream.
And you're entertaining on stream.
Because at that time...
I had more energy off stream to actually be entertaining.
Like...
Like just hanging out.
You know?
Just hanging out.
I had like...
I can entertain people.
Just hanging out.
Also to be fair.
Even when I hang out with people.
I say some fucking shit.
That would be like...
What the fuck.
Like...
So...
Because of that.
They were like you should start streaming.
And then I did.
I started streaming because of that.
And that's why I honestly...
Can't give advice on like how to do jokes.
And how to be entertaining.
Because like I said like...
The reason why I started streaming was because...
I literally got peer pressure too.
By like my friends.
Because they were like...
Oh my god.
You're pretty entertaining.
You should try streaming.
But I never committed to it.
I never like tried.
I just did it for fun.
Like I never actually tried tried.
And never kept it consistent.
I had like moments where I took like...
4 plus months break without telling anybody.
Because I never...
Like I didn't...
I didn't have much.
I was barely an affiliate.
I was just like fucking around.
And I was like...
I'm not gonna play streaming.
I didn't...
I was just like alright.
I didn't take it seriously.
Because I didn't see it as a career.
I didn't see it as a...
It would happen multiple times.
It wasn't like...
Oh yeah the first time it was 4 months and I came back.
I would be like 4 months and then I stream for like...
2-3 weeks or something.
Or like an entire month.
And then I disappear for another 6 months.
And then I was just like...
Whatever.
So I never took it seriously.
I just did it for fun.
Um...
That's really...
That's why I can't give like actual advice on this.
Because I feel like I'm not the right person to...
Uh...
To give advice on how to be entertaining.
Because for me it was just naturally within me.
Um...
Yeah you're lucky I don't do that anymore.
I actually don't do that anymore.
I think this is a job now.
We're so lucky that I actually see this as a job.
Yeah the BarkKnights...
The OG BarkKnights...
They're the strongest knights out there.
They...
Okay, the OG Discord...
Is like still running.
The OG Discord...
That I started off with...
That's been...
These people, those fans, they still exist.
And they're dragoons now.
But they've been supporting me even through all these hiatuses.
Like, it's actually crazy.
Oh my god.
But it's also like how I...
I forgot to give you guys this, but like...
How to nurture a community.
Because what you give to the community is what they give back to you.
So like, that's why you have to love and care your community.
Because they do so much to support you.
They... like, my Bark Knights, they've been there for me.
For all my hiatuses.
But like, I still try to like...
Like, let them know I care.
Like, in a way.
So like...
You have to be able to nurture a really loving and loyal community.
And first off, you need to name your community.
You didn't need a name.
They need to unite under a name.
And that is what I did.
You guys are dragoons.
We had Bark Knights before.
Um...
And stuff like that.
And...
You need to be...
Uh...
You need to be able to...
Know...
Do stuff...
Give back to your community.
You have to be able to give back to your community every so often.
When I was a Twitch streamer...
I would have like...
Sketch raffles.
By the way, which reminds me.
I need to fucking do the sketches and stuff.
From the donations.
Uh...
I'm sorry.
I've been so busy.
But that's...
Um...
When I was a Twitch streamer...
I would have sketch raffles.
And then the top...
Three...
And then like...
I would have like...
Raffles where like...
Um...
All my subs...
I would have like a lottery.
Where like...
Uh...
All my subscribers were put in a lottery.
And then...
Um...
If you win the...
I would pick like five subscribers.
To win art from me.
And then...
My most gifted subscriber...
I would send them a postcard.
To be like...
Thank you for...
For supporting me this month.
Like stuff like that.
I had made like little gift bundles and everything.
And I didn't even have like...
A large viewership.
I didn't have like...
But I had like a very dedicated community.
Because I really appreciated them.
I really appreciate what they did.
And like...
Sort of supporting me for this long.
And I would like...
Make like little like gift bundles and stuff.
For my top supporters.
And be like a personal postcard.
And be like...
Oh thank you for all the gifted subs.
I had...
Guys.
At one point...
I have...
I had 500 subs...
On Twitch.
But my average viewership...
Was 30 to 40.
Like...
Because I was like...
I was...
I just like...
I was just like...
Uh...
I really cared about my community.
I really cared about them.
I...
Because I...
I really appreciated them.
And...
Uh...
I really appreciated them.
And...
I tried very hard to show my appreciation.
Uh...
Here.
Thank you for the five gifted ships.
Thank you.
Um...
So...
Like...
It's all about...
Being a really good content curator...
Is making sure you give back to your community.
And is making sure...
You show them that you really care.
And that you care...
Because you can't be a content creator without your viewers.
And you have to show them that you appreciate it.
And that's why I try really hard...
With doing all these projects.
Doing all these like...
Fun things.
Like events.
And like...
Fun things with you guys.
And like trying to do lots of like...
Interactive stuff with you guys.
Is how I show I care.
And how I like...
Um...
And like...
All the things I...
Uh...
Want...
Because I couldn't be here without you guys.
So it has to be known.
Uh...
Alright.
Let's see...
Uh...
What else?
What else can I...
Uh...
Holy shit!
I almost...
Hahaha!
That's...
Woah!
I did not realize how long I've been streaming for.
Hahaha!
Hanta, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh...
Yeah, sorry small and care about those around you.
Glad to hear these tips, Doki.
I'm doing fine too.
But I cannot draw nor...
Draw nor do...
Anything more than playing games and talk...
With them.
What can I do?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's sometimes what they need.
The chat just wants your entertainment and your company.
You don't have to do more than like...
Uh...
What they're happy with.
Like...
By the time...
You...
Have a bigger...
Viewer base...
You can start reinvesting more into your channel.
Like when I first started...
All I did was just play video games.
And then I...
The bigger I got...
The more I reinvested...
Sometimes...
Like as you said...
You start small.
And then the bigger you get...
The more money you have earned...
Reinvest in your channel.
Or save money.
Honestly...
There's a lot of people who do...
Vtubing different ways.
They want to...
Use Vtubing to...
Be able to afford...
A house in the future...
Or like an apartment.
Um...
I put it in...
I reinvest in my content...
Because like...
I enjoy...
Making content...
And I enjoy reinvesting...
For the future.
And...
I'm playing...
More so...
Of the long game.
Because I...
Can save for a house...
For like...
An actual place to live...
Later on down the line.
For me...
This is me.
Don't follow this...
If you don't have a stable enough...
Like career.
But for me...
Content creation for me...
Obviously would never be long term.
Because...
Content creation...
Never has...
A long lifespan.
Because...
I don't have a long lifespan...
Within the internet.
Unless...
You're the 0.001%.
So for me...
I try to take advantage...
Of what I can do...
As a content creator.
And what I can invest in...
Uh...
This is not financial advice.
But I put my money...
Investing in my channel.
Because I know...
This is not...
For too long.
In terms of like...
My future.
And like...
I want to be able to experience this.
Uh...
Moment.
As much as I can.
Before I...
You know...
Can't do the internet stuff anymore.
So...
Obviously...
Um...
I want to be able to...
Reinvest all this...
To experience all the things...
I never got...
I would never be able to experience...
If it was like...
20 or 30 years...
In the line...
I would never be able to experience this.
So I want to...
Reinvest this in my channel.
To be able to do all these things...
That I've never got to do before.
Um...
And...
Because like...
I have a friend that keeps...
Fucking bugging me to...
Fucking buy a house.
One of my friends was like...
Please use that money to buy a house.
And I'm like...
No.
I'm gonna pay an animator to make another Doki Bites animation.
So...
So that's my...
I know I should...
I know I should buy something.
Instead of renting.
Okay...
Oh yeah...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you thank you.
Which part of content creation do you struggle with?
How do you get past those roadblocks?
Interact.
Socialize with people outside of just streaming.
I'm so bad at that.
I'm really bad on like...
Twitter socialization.
And just socializing with people.
I like talking to people.
I like talking to people like...
um...
what do you say?
I like talking to people like...
in a call.
But I hate talking to people on...
messaging stuff.
I don't know.
Like I rather like...
I think this is why like whenever I get a call...
with somebody I haven't like messaged in a while...
we would talk for hours.
We would talk for like 4 plus hours.
I remember like I haven't talked to this one person in a while...
and then like when we got in a call...
we would just like play a video game...
and just talk for like...
4 plus hours and then we're like...
oh fuck wait we're both busy tomorrow...
we should go to sleep.
It would be like 4 or 5 am or something.
It would be like 5 am and we're like oh shit.
Oh my god wait oh fuck.
Okay we should sleep cause...
we both have a busy work day.
Like stuff like that.
Like I don't like just messaging.
I like to be in a call with somebody.
Cause that's the majority of how...
I like to interact with people.
Um...
I'm like a person that like...
socialize via message.
And that's like one of the hardest part.
Because that's how you network.
A lot of networking is done via socializing on messages.
But I've...
done more network...
I personally feel like I've...
made more progress networking...
just talking to people on like...
on the call.
Like...
Music!
And Bob thank you for the super chat.
Thank you thank you.
I'm gonna leave the house here.
House fun!
Thank you!
Next one thank you for the super chat.
Thank you thank you.
It would make me very happy to see...
your more financially secure log there.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you thank you.
Alright guys I'm gonna answer...
two more questions and then I'm gonna call it here.
Chat.
I'm gonna call it here.
I'll answer two more questions for you guys.
If you guys have any.
Oh.
Um.
Questions I haven't answered before.
Uh.
Let's see.
Let me see real quick if there's anything.
Uh.
Also if you're a content creator.
I know like it's...
a lot of people are like...
ew.
But like if you're a content creator...
get Twitter blue.
It's... you have to.
I know it's...
sucks.
But like...
as a content creator...
you have to.
It's...
actually like really good.
Uh.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
Um.
Because like...
first off...
the... what is it?
Editing your post and being able to tweet...
really long tweets is really good.
It's just...
it sucks that that is like a bot...
service.
But like it's...
being able to make long tweets...
and being able to post longer videos...
as well as editing your tweets is just...
a really really helpful thing to have.
And I know it sucks...
but like it's a good investment in the long run.
Ha ha ha ha.
As a content creator.
Um.
Grace!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This will be my last question that I'll answer.
Thank you so much for the stream.
It's been incredibly educational.
How do you balance doing things out of passion...
versus because they are what's good...
for your growth?
Um.
You have to sacrifice...
things to grow.
Like you have to be able...
to uh... be able to sacrifice.
Of course you can still...
sprinkle... there's 7 days in a week.
Right?
You can do something you're passionate about...
in like half the week and it's something...
you know it's what I do.
I have a FOMO game.
Like once a week at least.
Or at most.
Once a week there is a FOMO game...
in the schedule like climbing or something.
Or like supermarket simulator.
Cause that is the game of the week!
Um.
It's fun.
But like obviously...
like how...
Some of them is like...
purposely rage games.
You know like the fucking...
climbing game!
It's fun for the viewers!
And it's fun to watch the streamers...
suffer.
So it's like you know...
sacrifices have to be made.
It's more so of like...
You have 7 days of a week.
You need to obviously balance...
the stuff you're passionate about...
versus the stuff that you want to grow with.
And you have to be able to...
sacrifice that to grow in whatever...
um...
way you want.
And uh...
And that's like the risk you have to take!
There's so many risks you have to take in content creation.
Streaming is a risk.
And you have to be ready to take these risks.
Uh but yes!
That would be my last question of the day!
I hope this stream...
was informative.
Um and that you were able to...
learn a little bit.
And that other VTubers...
are able to you know...
figure out what they want to do.
With what they want to stream.
And stuff like that.
I hope...
This might be like my only time I actually talk in depth...
about all of this.
So I hope it was informative.
There's obviously a lot of things I could have said.
There's obviously a lot more things I could have...
given insight on.
Um but I hope that...
what I gave you guys...
was enough...
to help you in some way.
And...
I hope you guys learned...
a lot about content creation.
Um...
The other thing I want to say...
is that you always want to keep eyes on you.
The reason why I was able to grow...
fast...
and big...
Um before you know...
as Doki...
was because I did things that I...
I was super passionate about.
And I love streaming.
And I loved...
I loved being involved in the community.
And I loved being involved outside of just...
Vtubing.
I tried to network...
outside beyond Vtubing.
And that's...
And I tried to do a lot of things.
I wanted to be involved in as many things as possible.
And that is like...
one of the biggest things with growing.
Is that you want to be...
You want to be like everywhere.
Type deal.
You want to be like everywhere so people will know...
recognize you.
And...
I also organized a lot of...
events and projects.
And that kept the momentum going.
And stuff.
I was willing to reinvest in my channel.
If you're willing to...
reinvest in your channel...
and know what your strongest suit are...
That is the best way...
to grow in my opinion.
Um...
And I knew how the algorithm...
worked.
I knew what would grow a channel.
And I knew what...
would benefit the algorithm.
And it's all about...
as long... the moment you realize...
what makes the algorithm works...
is when you realize...
how you can get bigger.
If you hit that boost...
initial boost...
that's when you know what can keep you going.
Um...
Um... but yeah.
Think long term.
It's not about short term.
It's all about long term.
Because like planning some of these things...
might take...
a long time.
But the long term effects...
is like...
so beneficial.
Cause sometimes my projects take a long time to plan.
But I know...
the moment...
I would upload it or the moment I do it...
I know people are gonna like it.
Because I put...
It's like you know when AAA companies...
rush a game for Christmas...
and you can tell it's rushed.
And like...
Oh you didn't put their real...
heart and soul into it.
Versus a game that took years to develop.
And like they clearly put a lot of...
investment into it and stuff like that.
Like that's the best comparison I can make.
Regarding this.
Don't be afraid to invest...
long term versus short term.
Because um...
If you...
believe in something enough...
Then like...
And like you know logically that this...
when you announce it or like when you...
actually put it out...
Like you know it's gonna work.
You know that this is what viewers want.
So like don't be afraid to reinvest...
for long term type deal.
Umm...
And that's like really how I felt like...
helped me a lot to grow...
the way I did...
before I came back as an indie.
Umm...
And uh...
Don't...
So being creative.
I know where I am.
I'm a producer.
My role is majority as a producer.
I have lots of ideas.
And I help and I provide like these ideas...
for people to make it into reality.
There's some people who are gifted in actually like...
creating it themselves.
Know where your strong suits are.
I know I don't have a lot of skills creating...
stuff in general.
But I know that I have lots of ideas.
That I know how to make it a reality.
Uh know what I want to make...
in reality.
And I know how to organize stuff really well.
I can plan things and organize and bring people together.
Umm...
Obviously...
Know where your strong suits are.
When you're really creative, creative streams...
You can make creative streams as a niche.
There's a lot of very creative streamers.
And there's a lot of like...
There's like one stream... one twitter account that I follow.
I can't bring up the name...
on the top of my head right now.
But they also... they always like retweet...
a lot of like very very creative streamers.
That do their... make their own...
like content.
They make their... create their own things.
Like create their own...
What is it called?
Create their own like...
Twitch interactions and...
uh like...
their own way of streaming.
Their own toggles.
It's actually crazy.
There's like people I want to hire.
Umm and try to like...
work with from those...
from those like... the people that...
do all these things.
Because it's so creative.
Like these are like coders.
People that can code and stuff.
To code better interactions.
Like they're very creative people.
And uh I would love to...
work with some of them in the future.
Because that's why...
I've been like following them along.
Because I like...
It helps me with ideas and like stuff I...
may potentially do in the future.
Uh so yeah.
Anyway guys...
Umm that is all I want to say.
As always everybody...
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me... Head to bed!
Because you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!